This is by far the most egregious, like, pro H3 propaganda Nick
has ever done. It's embarrassing.
Remember that time that Hasan shocked his dog? Remember that
time that Hasan bought a mansion? Remember that time that Hasan
bought a car? Remember that time that Hasan had a $1,300 shirt?
Remember that time that he had $1,600 glasses? You guys remember
that? No. No, you're not. No, you're not honest about it. You
lying
Someone find me Smaggle now and make him watch this on repeat
until he disavows Nicholas De Oreo entirely, okay? Well, hey
Smaggle.
We're finally ready to move on to the other Nick Nicholas De
Oreo stream, okay, from tonight. All right, so this is where
everything kind of goes crazy. I saw a couple of these clips
last time, but we need them for context. Hasan [__]
saying he's required by law to stay in a five-star hotel in Cuba
while wearing What was this? Uh fairly expensive sunglasses.
We've seen them before. I was saying tourism is the lifeline
for the Cuban economy as it stands currently.
Do you know how bad this Hasan [__] trip is for,
like, optics?
Cuz I'm the optics guy. I'm going to tell you how bad it is.
I'm the optics guy. I'm not I'm not even back yet. I didn't even
get my drink. I heard him say optics, I had to pause and walk
back over to my computer.
You know how bad this this trip is for optics? I'm the guy who
tells you what bad optics are. Why?
Ooh, who gave you that ability? Who said we care? Who Who did
any of this? He's just trying to make [__] up. You're
just making [__] up. You're lying
Oh, whoa, >> hey, we're on Twitch. You're a lying weasel,
okay? That's [__]
>> Whoa, whoa, none of that on Twitch. Okay, anyway.
Jesus Christ. Okay, we got to keep going. We got to keep pushing.
When you've got, and I [__] you not, when you've
got Xander Hall retweeting [__] about how the average
annual salary in Cuba is $156
and that Hasan Pike's car Hasan Piker's Cartier glasses are 1,300
bucks, when Xander Hall is retweeting the socialist meme, something
bad something dramatically bad is occurring right now in your
in your career. This is Dude, these guys have been fighting the
Hasan [__] house allegations for like five years,
all right? They're now aligned with everybody else. The government
has very limited resources. Again, this should really This should
really give Nick a hint in the right direction. Guess who's on
your side?
Xander Hall.
Xander Hall's on your side.
Hey Nick, what do you think of Xander
How How smart do you think Xander Hall is? Actually, you know
how bad it is? Xander Hall agrees with me.
Fantastic, man.
And the Oh, by the way, people are saying they're not even nice.
Dude, if I'm spending near a thousand dollars on glasses, they
better have speakers in them. I could not imagine buying designer
sunglasses that are literally just sunglasses. Maybe I'm totally
off on that. The only glasses I'm spending that much money on
literally have a screen and they're not even that much money.
American government makes it
for Americans to Dude, for $800, which is a total rip-off, you
can get like the top of the line glasses that you could plug
your switch into and have a 10-ft screen while you're sitting
on the train uh playing like Super Mario World or something on.
Like, that's that that's what you can get for like $800.
I don't I'm I don't know, dude. I don't get the designer sunglasses.
They were ever they want when they're in Cuba. They have to stay
in what they've declared as five-star hotels, right?
I'm telling you all this because, like, even the five-star hotels
are not like, you know, they're Yeah, the five-star hotel meme.
Now, everybody and their mother on Twitter with no community
notes that I've seen is saying that Hasan [__] did
not have to stay at a five-star hotel. There were other options
for him. And again, he he rolled up to Where? Where? Cuz I Listen.
By the way,
now I I know exactly what happened. Cuz I said, "Oh, Hasan probably
is just listening to what somebody told him." Now, I have a strong
feeling
that Ryan Grim told him, right?
Cuz Ryan Grim's just the guy that I'm I'm sure Hasan is just
like, "Ryan Grim comes correct on stuff. He He would just tell
me, and that's what it is, right?" So, Ryan Grim's got the explanation.
He tweets it out.
Dude, imagine you come back, you're doing like a an unambiguously
nice thing an unambiguously good work that almost everybody should
be cool with.
And you come back and it's just people making [__]
up about you and like your flotilla and how how the trip went
and that you guys actually killed a bunch of
It's got to be so blackpilling.
It's got to like actually shake your faith in humanity.
That you've you've gone and done this unambiguously good thing.
You didn't even You didn't even broadcast it. You didn't even
like go out and show a whole bunch of video of you guys doing
like charitable work,
You come back and people are like, "Ryan Grim and Hasan killed
a bunch of people,
Dude, what? >> Dude, this is another one. I'm going to
show this in a bit. He rolled up with a You know that Cartier
nail bracelet that I was joking about on stream saying that I
think it looks kind of cool?
Hasan [__] has a ring of that in solid gold that
he was wearing to Cuba. And he's wearing it to Cuba. I'm telling
you all this because, like, even the five Humble Parker, yeah.
No, the thing is that it's it's becoming increasingly obvious
that they're like uh so [laughter] social democrat. Now, they're
they're socialist hyper-consumeristic
uh democracy
orgy having
This guy doesn't understand politics. This guy's What What What
are you doing here, man? This is, again, this is Nick's minstrel
show that where he's now Dude, he was running the minstrel show
where he just did what Massa told him. Well, guys, I'm going
to tell you about how bad Hasan is today.
Okay? He's He's running his minstrel show. And then they made
another minstrel show right next to his. And now he's having
to fight for his life. And he's just be He's
He's just further demeaning himself over and over and over again.
Bro, you
He doesn't know anything about the politics involved. He doesn't
know anything. He just shows up and he Guys, Hasan is like the
most hyper-consumerist hyper-capitalist bro.
Said he wasn't a Destiny orbiter, shows up with all of the Destiny
talking
Hasan is just the most hyper-consumerist hyper-capitalist guy
I've ever met in my entire life. He's just like totally
it's not 2019. It's not 2020. It's not
It's 2026, okay?
It's 2026.
I don't know. Get
Pick a side, I guess. I He seems to be.
I And then figure out the talking points. Figure out what you
should be saying cuz he keeps weaving back and forth between
different types of
Uh is it a morally bad thing? Is it a an optics thing? It's just
I don't know what to do with this anymore. Now, they're they're
socialist hyper-consumeristic
uh democracy
orgy having Hasan Democracy orgy having.
Democracy orgy having. I apologize. I see he's doing Destiny
talking points. That's just what
That's just nonsense. That's totally nonsensical. If you hate
Hasan, you're not You don't think he loves democracy. He's not
having a democracy orgy. Democracy orgy having.
You hear the typing. sick uh democracy
orgy having Hasan [__] is not really living up to
the dream that they had set for him. five-star hotels >> His
shirt What? shirt cost $500. I've heard that it's upwards of
that. Like, it's more than that. >> are not like, you know,
they're He's He's unironically like slobbering on himself for
30 seconds.
This [__]
$500 shirt.
I make a statement. That's what this That's what this stream
is tonight, I guess. That's what he's trying to do. Like, that's
what we're doing here. It's performative. Yeah, he wants everyone
to believe he's fighting the good fight while, like, reaping
all the rewards. At least I'm honest about it. >> It's
not like No. No, you're not. No, you're not honest about it.
You lying
Listen, he wants to He wants to be a virtue signaling loser who
reaps all the rewards, but at least I'm honest.
About what? What are you honest about?
You're just transparently running with a
Dude, you're He's probably He's like openly doing He is everything
Everything he thinks Hasan is is what he's become.
Like a propagandist who just runs with narrative, doesn't care
about facts at all? That's Nick. And he's still getting his [__]
pushed in by Glam, okay? Even with all of this debasement, he's
still getting his [__] pushed in by the H3
slumber party duo, okay? I don't even know what to call them.
This is what the American government has declared five-star hotels.
Yeah, I still He's saying that he did humanitarian aid as well.
And the only clip I've seen of him explaining it is saying that
he was just hanging out with the boys like with the boys at the
bar handing people wads of cash. But regardless,
in comparison to the situation on the island, it's it's a like
it's a prosperity, pretty much. Dude, him saying the word prosperity
with the And experiencing that >> Dude, he just He just
disappeared, dude. He's the guy from The Boys when they shoved
a bomb up their up his butt in the first episode. Who is that?
Translucent. He just turned into >> The economy is like
Awesome. Definitely Sick reference. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. >> Definitely.
Dude, oh my god, this is even funnier. He's pulling Dude, he's
in the He's like, "Guys, listen, dude, It's so [__]
up the way these guys live. It's terrible. Also, here's my room
service espresso delivered
It's so funny. When we watched this and he missed the joke from
last night and now he rewatches the clip so he can actually land
the plane and make the joke tonight.
So, he [__] it up last night. He missed it. A chatter
pointed it out and he's like, "Oh, that is Oh, no. Somebody on
the subreddit pointed it out." And he's like, "Oh, that is funny,
actually." And now he's back the next night to land the plane
and make the joke that he failed to make the night before. Guys,
guys, isn't that awesome? It's like
He's totally talking about prosperity. He's talking He's talking
about how hard they have it. Sips his espresso. The dichotomy
between this and and their way of life. Sips his espresso.
He's in this tiny little quirky [__] It's so funny,
dude. Sips from the room service five-star espresso.
To the little cup with the pinky out with his [__]
with the ring Not that That's not the ring. This is That's a
different ring. I'm not even kidding. It's a different ring.
Well, if I were to ever if I I mean, not ever, but like I I hope
to come back and when I do, I'll probably
not abide by the American res- This is This is actually like
when you know somebody's upset or they're trying to they're like
really working with
sipping on that five-star espresso
Yes, he got espresso at his hotel. You're just describing exactly
what everybody sees.
restrictions. He's trying to invent it, >> just like, "I'm
going to come here and I'm going to break the law."
Dude, are you kidding me? I think that's a crazy thing to say.
I didn't pick that up last time I saw that. No American visiting
Cu- I told when Kathy when Ethan tweeted or sorry, when Ethan
made the Instagram story about like about the tiny cup, I told
Queenman, "You need to go edit like one of you in your little
tiny cup sips. Okay, you need to go edit a clip together that's
just that Instagram story with you taking your your little cup
sip at the end cuz I think I think Ethan did the similar seething
on Instagram, okay? Which by the way, don't discount how important
that is in Nick coming back to make this joke, okay?
Queenman in his tiny espresso cup. I Somebody's got to do that
with a Queenman clip. Come on. >> Cuba. No Americans visiting
Cuba do not have to stay at five-star hotels. However, they must
avoid certain government-owned hotels due to restrictions. There
are privately owned boutique hotels available for US travelers.
10 seconds of research. How would the US government know where
you stay? Well, I mean, listen.
Not every person who goes there is like a famous person streaming
it, right? >> You're supposed to keep your receipts, but
in practice it's never checked.
Like a lot of laws, it probably never comes up. Um
But again, not every person who goes there live streams what
hotel they're at. God, it's [__] me up so much that
I have to stay in this five-star hotel while everyone else is
suffering.
>> Dude. That is the same joke again. Yeah. >> Oh
my god. Dude, it's so free. This guy every other year he's in
like some crazy consumeristic drama. My dude, look at my socialist.
His cup is small. He's required by law to use Starlink as well,
I guess. He's denying this, but I mean, it's pretty I I don't
know what else he'd be using. Apparently, he's required by law
to live in a mansion when he gets back home. Couldn't possibly
live amongst the peasants in modest state. How dare you? In his
own words, it's just shelter. This is so debasing, dude.
All of the
Bro, I need I need the apology form signed from all of the commentary
people who wrote with this guy. Who Dude, when
when Chud Logic said he was sucking Ethan Klein's for shekels,
that was far too kind. That was far too kind a way to describe
whatever the [__] this is,
Dude, that was nice. That was Chud being too nice again to Nicholas.
This is humiliating. I'm starting to feel like nauseous watching
it. Okay? The dude is designer dog that was that was free. It
was a free designer dog. Him having to justify his wealth is
so funny. His mansion is a shelter. His Porsche is transportation.
His $2,000 wardrobe might as well be a humble sack. His designer
dog he abuses was a rescue. I think that you've earned the classic
deflection. I'm about to evaporate you with socialist Dude, Chronic
Sonic picking fights with Glam on Twitter. Hold on.
Nicholas DeOrio
coming back at Chronic Sonic. Well, Glam Glam tweets, "Retract
and apologize." Let's listen to which one this was, precisely.
convoy. But like, you put on this concert
bad optics or you join this concert
Her and Nick really do just say the exact same things. Like why
Dude, that's [__] up. Like I would never have been
in a million years imagined that Glam would just have the same
level of analysis as Nick. Like I thought I thought Nick did
some work. But to the rest of us, it just looks like you're throwing
a concert on an island that is suffering specifically from power
outages.
You're staying at a hotel while the rest of the island is blacked
out and the hotel [snorts] is using the generators
um while hospitals
have no generators and people are dying because their ventilators
go out. >> Wow. It's like Hasan killed those people. So,
Ryan Grim, if you guys missed it, tweeted out that basically
this is just not true, okay?
This is just literally a total lie. And Chronic Sonic says, "Well,
Glam, retract and apologize."
And Glam says, "Posts like this kind of undercut your demands
of me, bud."
Listen, I hope these This just wants all the food for herself.
Very rude posts.
Very rude post, Chronic Sonic. Very rude. What the [__]
man?
What the heck? The The death rows of Nick's career is just copy-pasting
Glam. What a journey. It really was a long way down, wasn't it?
Yeah, I mean, dude. He He He pulls you in on um Guys, we need
free college and then all these all these teenagers like hoarding
into his chat. And then he he really keeps you there by electrocuting
his dog. That's That's what gets people to stay. Kaya got shocked,
guys. Kaya got shocked. Kaya got shocked. You remember that time
Kaya got shocked and it was like really bad? You remember that
time that Hasan shocked his dog? Remember that time that Hasan
shocked his dog? Remember that time that Hasan bought a mansion?
Remember that time that Hasan bought a car? Remember that time
that Hasan had a $1,300 shirt? Remember that time that he had
$1,600
glasses? You guys remember that? Do you guys remember that? Remember
Fomenko?
Remember Fomenko?
Do you guys remember John Swan? Again, I'll say it again in case
you guys weren't here. Nicholas DeOrio has totally dejected
like
totally dejected gotten
white women as an audience now. Total wine moms. Instead of watching
reruns of The Office for the 600th time, tune into his stream
to get the same thing. Like totally brain dead, totally just
totally brain dead like slop fed down their throats, okay? They
would be watching The Office. They would be watching What's another
one? Parks and Rec. They would be watching one of these shows
for the 600th time, but instead they're going to watch the reruns
through Nick cuz actually, it's even less creative or ambitious
than just watching Netflix reruns, okay? That's his audience
entirely.
People who have no interest in hearing something new, people
who have no interest in learning something new, seeing anything
new. They just want the same jokes shoveled into their mouths
over and over again while they drink themselves into oblivion.
That's it. That's the entire audience. That's everybody, okay?
Nobody who has an ounce of intellectual curiosity, who has an
ounce of need to be entertained in any legitimate way, in any
creative way, in any new way. That's it. The Those are the Those
are the people who watch. They have nothing like that. There
is no spark there. It's sad to watch It's sad to see Nicholas
reduced to this, okay? Although, now I'm starting to just think
about it how much I must have how much I must have been seeing
in the past with rose-tinted glasses.
It's rough. It's rough. I can't handle >> Dude, the textbook
definition of champagne socialist. Hasan is pretty much Napoleon
from Animal Farm. Wait, The Office is good. The Office is good,
Stalinist love. When you've watched The Office for the 800th
time and you're legitimately sitting down after work and just
watching The Office with a glass of and that's it. Like focused
on it. Putting it on the background, whatever. Putting it on
as you fall asleep, whatever. But these people will
rewatch over and over. Friends was the other one I wanted. Yes,
thank you,
Yes. Okay. Friends was the other one.
And they found a new thing that doesn't change. It's always the
same. It's always predictable. It's never going to hurt their
feelings. It's never going to be like offensive. It's just going
to be the same thing every single night. And it's the Nicholas
DeOrio stream.
>> Oh my god, dude. This clip is great, too. We didn't
see this one yet. This is totally new. Communist Marxist Hasan
[__] complains how AT&T shut his account down
cuz he used too much data in Cuba and now he fears for his safety.
I think he's home already, right? I remember I I I opened my
phone yesterday and it was like Trump threatens military action
on on Cuba and I'm like, dude, this this is this is so [__]
insane. This is This could not happen at a funnier time. >> And
boy, do I have He was threatening military action before they
went there. He was literally posturing for military action before
they even went there, idiot. my show for you. Boy, do I have
Hasan Hasan realized that he might get cuz they said it after
he went. No, he knew full well that that was the intention of
the United States. That regime change is at the intention of
the United States in Cuba. tell you all about the things that
have happened. My
No, he only did that after Hasan pulled up. Yeah, Trump Trump
saw Hasan land in Cuba. He was following some of these people.
He He saw Hasan land in Cuba and he's like, "Oh, [__]
We got to Get over there, guys. Get over there now. No more Iran.
We're We're making peace in Iran. We have to go after Cuba. We
have to get them. So true. It's basically Dude, the audio being
terrible is awesome, too. >> It's just a non-functioning
brick at this point. AT&T shut off my account
because I'm AT&T's his biggest hater. >> just started
insulting me viciously on >> Dude, breaking news. I'm hearing
that AT&T is a fan of the streamer Destiny. >> using
too much data in Cuba.
for my own safety, I guess. Even though I functionally have had
no data in Cuba whatsoever. But we're still doing the damn thing.
And uh I have a bunch of interviews lined up with Cuban doctors,
regular Cuban folk. >> He's home now, right? Like he's
already back? folks. And uh you know, we're going to talk about
that.
Nah. How long did he go? For like less than a week? >> energy
grid, but before that obviously I'm going to be Dude, Hasan [__]
only goes on the vacations in extremely sus places. Hey guys,
we're going to be doing a hangout in um
Definitely definitely wasn't predictable from who Marco Rubio
takes donations from that the Secretary of State and the foreign
policy of this administration would be anti-Cuba possibly with
the explicit goal of regime change in Cuba. Definitely couldn't
have predicted that right off the bat. Yeah, people are saying
this is his vacation.
Yes. Obviously I'm going to be Dude, Hasan [__] only
goes on the vacations in extremely sus places. Hey guys, we're
going to be doing a hangout in um
to talk about all the good things about their local government.
Is a failed snarker right here. The best Hasan snarking trip
was the Australia one cuz he melted down in his Discord about
how nobody watched and it was super funny cuz he's literally
melting down in his Discord about how nobody watches and somebody
comes in and goes, "Hey Hasan, did you think about like going
to the beach and just having fun and swimming? I'd tune in if
you did that." And he went, "I already did that. I did that today.
You didn't watch."
That was the funniest I've ever seen,
And also we had the the don't drink diet coke on stream anymore
girl as well, okay? It was [__] awesome. That Australia
trip was [__] awesome.
How do you not know that? That's not a sus place.
Hey guys, I'm feeling a little I think I'm going to go to Cuba.
What do you mean I shouldn't be staying in a five-star
hotel?
>> Dude, I got to stop yelling like that. My voice is straight
now from yelling. Oh boy. Talk. He went there for now. He didn't
go back and chill. He says the situation that we're in Cuba.
Dude, this Dude, the Cuba conspiracy. Streamer Hasan [__]
responds to everything including about being his lie about being
forced to stay in a five-star hotel by the American government.
Is that a narrative spin? Um dude, when It's so funny that Nicholas
goes to like a known from his community that every one of his
viewers mocked mercilessly
until they left cuz he's an intellectually like
disingenuous, okay? He he sucks. And now he's gone to like the
dregs of that community to get like his updates. And he's going
to look he's just going to be humiliated for it. He's just like
making [__] up. You can't you can't write it any
better than this, okay? Maybe there is a god cuz the universe
is starting to feel scripted a little bit, okay? It's >> When
in reality people are calling him out for grifting because all
he did in Cuba was stream from his hotel room, perform off-stream
interviews for content, and drink. That's far from the humanitarian
aid that was initially
I didn't have much internet the last two days and I couldn't
check the insane narrative spin. What a nightmare. How do people
live like this? They just sit around and justify the US government
tormenting smaller countries to feel powerful? Listen, if you
thought you just looked at the worst possible take from this
entire conflict, I actually I I really I endorse Taylor Lorenz
once again. Taylor Lorenz has the Taylor Lorenz is kind of histrionic
to tell you the truth.
>> It's I don't like hate her for it. It's just very funny.
Um if you're going to Cuba, you should wear a mask. >> Absolute
worst position >> Dude, are you good? >> ever seen
in this drama. Can he Um it could be true. You're going to but
I it actually probably isn't true. I think
I think Cuba is actually like less invested with like airborne
disease than most places, right? They actually overprescribe
like
antibiotics and stuff there, right?
Like they they actually don't have a lot
I feel like this is the one thing they do well. No? >> If you're
traveling They don't have parasites. They don't have um They
don't have parasites. They don't have like infectious disease
as much. to Cuba or any impoverished community or just generally,
you should be wearing a
We are 6 years in to an ongoing pandemic
and um airborne diseases
are real no matter how many leftists want to scream and stomp
their feet and shout RFK talking points.
I mean realistically, she probably is right about any like high-density
population area. Like wearing masks probably is important that
humans humans didn't evolve in a place where you had the kind
of population density humanity gets to now. Probably you should
actually wear a mask if you're in like a super congested area.
But I I'm not going to cuz I hate it. But I you know, you know,
I'm not going to like mock her for it. She's kind of tell She's
kind of telling the truth. Just all of us are like This is like
somebody in the 1930s being like, "You know there's no reason
not to wear a seatbelt, right?" And you're like, "What are you
What are you like a whiny little
Take that seatbelt. What do you mean a seatbelt? You think you
can be strapped into this car? Go flying outside go flying over
your dash out over the lack of windshield and hit the ground
like a real man, okay?
Disease is a tool of genocide.
Cuba is experiencing a health crisis.
Adding to that by spreading deadly airborne diseases is bad.
Activists who weren't thinking about No, I would never make this
tweet and I'm not even really defending it. I'm saying like it's
probably true that she'll be like vindicated at some point. But
I I just can't, okay? I can't. It's It's a soy step too far.
>> mitigating disease on their trip should simply take
the L and do better. Get a mask. Put it on. It's not hard.
Why are we making it like an impoverished thing? I think anyone
can get sick, right? Like what's happening here? Holy Dude, this
is actually a subhuman take from jackass Taylor. Taylor's like,
"Oh my god, they're they're they're done." This is This is a
Pokimane filtering thing, isn't it? This is like a Pokimane
filtering moment right here. Where if you get like irrationally
upset at Taylor Lorenz getting histrionic about airborne disease,
I think that's a filtering moment 100%.
This what Like at at worst this woman has
like an anxiety disorder around illnesses. She has like a phobia.
That's like the worst possible situation here, right? That's
the worst thing she could be doing is taking her her phobia,
her irrational fear, and making it everybody else's problem.
Realistically, she might actually have some kind of point here.
But at worst she's like just posting with some phobia she has.
Dude, it's no reason to get this angry. >> Dying in Cuba.
Let me make it about my immune system.
An ongoing six-year pandemic. And if you wonder why half the
words in this tweet are muted, I do have the word pandemic muted
on Twitter. It usually collects all of her tweets that get retweeted
out of my feed and puts them away from my vision so I don't do
endless Taylor Lorenz segments. But she is absolutely insufferable.
Every opportunity that she could pipe up and be like, "You actually
Guys, it's 2026.
Why are we not wearing our masks?
What are you doing at that party?
Did you not realize that we are currently in a pandemic?" >> insulting
me viciously on Twitter. What do you mean the Americans just
won the gold medal?
There's got to be a thing like this that
What can I compare this to? There's got to be like a comparison.
Mask got like totally by the by like the
culture war basically. Cuz there there probably almost there
almost certainly is no reason you shouldn't wear a mask if you
are sick. If you get sick, you should wear a mask if you ever
have to go outside. Like 100% that is something that is like
good for the rest of society. I'm trying to think of something
that like a rule you should follow for the rest of society that
gives that's like minorly inconveniencing you.
It's actually like a symptom of a very sick society that you
won't do something that actually helps everybody. It helps literally
every part of society
doing it, right?
Wear masks around the poor? Well, I think what she's saying is
that because they have like worse access to like clean water,
clean food, clean everything that they're more likely to get
some kind of infectious disease, right? Probably. Not just that
the the poor are dirty and diseased.
There's probably an actual reason. There's like there's like
a comparison here that would make it make sense for people. Oh
right. Yeah, sure. Maybe um You could compare it to like doctors
washing their hands.
It actually might be a little comparable to that. Just maybe
not with the disastrous downsides. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Asian countries
do this.
Yeah. Oh, this could be true, too. Yeah. Lack of electricity
meaning they don't have effective hospitals
effective medical infrastructure, sure. They wear their masks
during the 2026 Winter Olympics. Like dude, I'm I'm tired of
this [__] bro. I am tired of this. I am tired of
Dude, low white cell count. Here, I'll I'll give you the perfect
You want to talk, Taylor? And have a reasonable perspective on
this. Like this tweet from Blair White, I actually don't hate.
My first instinct was to clown her, but I actually feel bad.
She's in a prison.
I do feel like this is possibly just like a phobia that makes
her post this stuff like this. Again, she could be correct. But
it could just be a phobia. That's like the If you're If you're
annoyed about it, that's the reaction you should have. Is I just
think this person's like irrationally in fear of this, and she
posts about it. I'm going to ignore it. Maybe she's immunocompromised.
I think she says she is. I don't know if she is. Right? I've
no reason to really doubt it, but
Anyway, I think during COVID she got She said she got um
She got like uh diagnosed with something during COVID, but I
I don't know the details. So, I I don't know any of the underlying
details there, so hard hard to say. Chewonhead tweet. These people
loved COVID. Inside all day, censorship online, green light to
be moral busybodies and skull people for making maskless for
being maskless, sorry, not trusting the science, overly cautious,
bubble wrapped society. The world was a massive longhouse Asian
paradise. Haha, very longhoused.
am probably going to die with a similar attitude in terms of
my reaction. I I'm just like, dude, who cares? All right, we
are back to the Nick stream. Taylor What is it? What Is it red
or white What count is it? Um dude, [laughter] apparently Taylor
has super AIDS, and her immune system just cannot function. All
right? That's the beeper Taylor Lorenz. Oh god, dude. Taylor's
immune system was weakened during the bubonic
>> White count Low white count Taylor, dude. Not not low-T
Tonka, low low white count Taylor.
Uh white count for immune systems.
Low-T Tonka. That That friend zoning clip still in his head.
He's just just throwing a jab at a Tonka saw who's been off the
internet for like 8 years. Yeah, I do I'm [__] I'm
so tired of listening to of hearing Taylor drone on about her
weakened immune system. I do not care. I'm sitting here thinking
like
has COVID started a GoFundMe? I would like to I would I would
like to donate to COVID. Huh? No, not to COVID prevention. I
would like to bolster the disease if there's any way I can do
it. I'm so tired of anti-COVID sentiment on my timeline right
now in 2026. All right, I'm looking to support COVID any way
I can. Yeah, free COVID. It's been 6 years, guys. Free COVID.
I'm sick of I'm sick of hearing about COVID. I am sick of COVID.
It's what it's I am sick of it. For lack of a better term. Wow.
[laughter] I I can't take it anymore. I can't I I can't take
it anymore.
I think it's uh just because we have sort of mirrored careers
that I also hate her. >> Keffals tweet on Nicholas DeOrio.
Keffals appreciated the shout-out.
I wish COVID was real so Taylor could get it ASAP. >> Dude,
I'm Yeah, that's the joke. That's the Congratulations.
Random wine mom, you got the joke. Look at Dude, I I honestly,
the first thing I thought when I saw that they had a nationwide
blackout while Hasan was streaming on a generator was, dude,
vaxed? Like got no internet in the vaxed? Huh, crazy. Wow, holy
[__] The internet was vaxed. The US provides a list
of hotel Okay, so this is uh Hasan explaining how American government
forces him to stay in whatever they declare a five-star Cuban
hotel is here. Yes, you should get off the internet for more
than just 10 days of your moment. No, no, I meant like
like mishaps.
And nuisance I think we saw this clip last time, but it's the
reader added context, I want to say. nuisances.
Like minor inconveniences.
The rebranded context. >> a very I I I look at it very
differently. I'm sure I'll I'll reset back I'll snap back to
like being my spoiled self. I will snap back to being my spoiled
self. >> But uh I will say this much.
So, couple things. Number one. The United States government literally
>> Dude, here's why it's the government's fault that I'm
a like a pathetic materialistic loser.
>> has made >> way, to be clear, materialism is awesome,
and I am absolutely materialistic.
But I do not larp as a socialist online. That is the difference
for people who did not get the comment.
I just don't understand what the Like Okay, I understand superficially
what the connection is. I do.
But it's like I think this would be an ideal way to organize
the economy.
Probably is pretty disconnected. Like there's some cultural hate
of like communist types, socialist types towards very rich people.
Sure.
But in terms of the actual ideology, there's not really something
that says Hasan shouldn't do this or can't do
He's arguing for a philosophical shift
while not employing a weaker philos- philosophy in the moment
while that shift is not happening. He's advocating a true shift,
but it hasn't shifted. I don't know, it's whatever. >> for
Americans to stay wherever they want in Cuba. Okay? Yeah, true.
True? I didn't think about that. >> Wait, maybe I haven't
seen this one. Wait, what the
I don't think I've seen this one. Dude, he's like, all right,
here, we're going to lay down the law, and then his Cuban Wi-Fi
just exp- At straight rate, can socialists be materialists, too?
Your commie expert, please inform us if DeOrio is making sense
or making [__] up. Thanks, Aaron.
Yeah, you're asking if the person with like the
the carnival
prize section background, if you could be materialist.
I geez, I wonder what she's going to say. explodes.
>> Dude, all right, this is what we're going to talk about
right now, okay? I'm going to get to the bottom of the
He sounds like RFK. It's functioning industry that remains. So,
they're like actively trying to
funnel resources into tourism so they can like bring money in.
Bring money into the economy.
I'm Israel high. I'm Israel high.
It's good. We're good. We're good. Dude, is Nick going to let
that Is Nick going to know what that means? Is Nick going to
get it? I don't think Nick's going to get it. That's so funny.
Oh, that's actually a good joke from Hasan.
So, I I assume this is what he means, okay? His stream is going
out His stream is going out His stream is going out, and he goes,
I'm Israel high. I'm Israel high. He's He's saying, I love Israel,
okay? He's saying, glory to Israel He's saying something like,
I love Israel.
Hoping the stream bandwidth will come back, okay?
That's the joke. That That one is a little anti- That one is
a little control everything, okay? But it's just a joke. It's
funny. >> I was saying tourism is the lifeline for the
Cuban economy as it stands
The government has very limited
And the American government make It's just built into every single
streaming application, okay? Sends a ping to the data center
nearest you, and let's you let's everybody know that connection
is prioritized now, okay? That connection cannot die. This person's
praising Israel. Do not let their internet go Yes, 100%. It's
magic.
>> for Americans to stay wherever they want when So, readers
added context, US regulations prohibit Americans from lodging
in government-controlled properties, including many luxury hotels,
rather than requiring stays in five-star hotels. They're in Cuba.
They have to stay in what they've declared as five-star hotels.
Right? >> know why he keeps saying it has to be a five-star
hotel.
I I I like there is I have waited multiple days for somebody
to post the evidence of what he is saying, and I have yet to
see it. Ryan Grim just said it. Well, I guess Ryan Grim didn't
post some evidence. The thing
Sorry, the thing nobody is taking into
is that a So, unless you're a government-run
or like some super high-
quality establishment, you probably don't even have the money
to keep the lights on. Right? While the while the island is under
blockade.
Like there's energy blockade. Nobody's coming. There's no tourism
right now. So, you probably just shut your [__] down,
right? You probably shut your [__] down, send everybody
home, and figure something else out. There's probably only a
very few select places even open
that aren't either run by the government
Yeah, that aren't run by the government, cuz that's the the line.
Man, I can't wait dude to see growth for the Ryan Grim tweet.
Are we going to get that
Dude, there's no way we're on Hasan the whole time. No, no, no,
no, no. Okay, we only got a little bit left. Like I looked at
this last time on stream, and it didn't say what he said it was.
Like in a I'm telling you all this The cup is amazing. The cup
really sells it. Because like even the five-star hotels are not
like, you know, This is the part we did see where he's like,
guys, it's five stars for Cuba, okay? Let's not act like I'm
living in a lap of luxury, all right? These guys get paid six
pesos an hour. So, yeah, it's a five-star hotel in a third world
country, guys. Let's not go crazy over here.
>> It's not like
So, again,
right? I remind them that the Trump administration changed its
rules so that private businesses, like American-owned hotels
that Americans are required to stay at, are allowed to buy imported
oil from the government, which means all
are not allowed to import oil, okay? All
But the government the the government-owned facilities are not
allowed to buy oil. They can't run generators. This hotel can
run a generator because it is not owned by the Cuban government.
And Americans are allowed to stay there. That's why the lights
are on. That's why nobody else has power, okay?
That's what's going on. So, while while Nick is seething about
this, in the
the thing that's actually happening is
Everything they blamed on Hasan is objectively the fault of the
US government. Just full stop.
It was already that way, but now it's nice seeing that it's even
more that way, I guess.
This is what the American government has declared five-star hotels.
But regardless,
in comparison to the situation on sips >> a spray Yeah.
It's it's a Like it's a prosperity pretty much. And experiencing
that dichotomy is like >> He's like he's he's Joseph Stalin
if he was a Twitch streamer instead of a dictator of a country.
really [__] me
So so true. He's he's Stalin, guys. He's Stalin for sure.
>> Like in my experience like uh Check it out. The coffee
is great. >> Hold on. Wait, there's something totally awesome
about Hasan sitting in Cuba
sipping an espresso watching Israel get hit with ballistic missiles.
Dude, what?
>> Like in my experience like uh He's just watching this
[__] missile come down. is great. Into Moda, boom.
The coffee is great.
Oh, this coffee is
Did you have He can't even keep his He can't even keep the act
going while he's sipping his tiny cup.
Well, you were to ever if I I mean not ever, but like I I hope
to come back and when I do I'll probably
not abide by the >> fun being a virgin. Dude. I'm not.
He's getting bullied into breaking the law.
He's just He's reacting to all the same clips again. This is
funny. Wait, look at this clip. It's so good. It lags while he's
Just got Listen, the Hasan content was so good. He's got to cover
it twice in two nights, okay? It's not that he knows Qlenn and
Harley are going to cover it and take all of his viewers. It's
not
It's just that they're so good. He's got to watch them again.
He's got to watch them all again, guys.
Come on, guys. I got to watch them
Is it really important context? >> He's drinking it. >> When
I do I'll probably Look on the bottom right. It's perfect.
not abide by the American restrictions.
Okay. [laughter] Just to be clear, when I said that thing about
the Office reruns and the Friends reruns, when I when I said
that tonight, I said that before I knew he was literally doing
a rerun of his own stream from last night, okay?
I didn't know that. It just Listen, the universe just shapes
itself to the things I say sometimes, okay? That's just That's
just the way it is. He starts lagging while he's drinking his
tiny cup.
Seeing people survive in such conditions
does make you really reconsider how spoiled you are, you know?
And Dude, this is some Like people will criticize Mr. Beast for
in Africa. Like what is it? The irrigation systems. And they'll
be like, "Dude, Hasan [__] is my hero. He was handing
out bundles of money like the stuff you get when you kill a hooker
in Grand Theft Auto to people walking on the street." >> Who's
doing that? I just That's humanitarian aid.
Really doing the same thing? How can I possibly be doing the
same thing? I'm watching him from 5 hours
What do you mean I'm doing the same
This is 5 hours ago.
It's a live stream with 2600 viewers right now.
How can I be doing the same thing?
I'm literally live reacting to his content. [laughter] I am certainly
I am certainly spoiled. He's He's to defend his privilege. So
yeah, they they do that. And then it also shows this. Below is
US Department of State Cuba prohibited accommodations list. We
We watched this last time. Um
The properties owned or controlled by the Cuban government are
prohibited.
Official government of Cuba defined by
I think somebody also had this to show. No, they didn't. Where
was it?
Oh, here.
Most five-star hotels are blacklisted. You can easily filter
hotels by class on the website like TripAdvisor and filter out
five-star hotels manually. Hasan is just straight-up lying.
>> Ah, and it literally says travel alert US licensing
restrictions.
or he's just a [__] Yeah, I don't know about that
one. He's probably like, "Hey, I'm going to like a a potentially
hostile country that I have to tell everybody who's like really
cool and based, but I'm going to stay in the safest possible
location and tell everybody I had a great time." That's my
I don't think Hasan booked his room.
I think somebody like somebody who's organizing this probably
booked all of the rooms for the people going, right? Like you
don't all individually book rooms in this place. That wouldn't
make any sense.
opinion, of course. I'm going to go to a place that might not
be the most safest place on the planet. So I'm going to >> where
Cuba is. Do you think Do we think Nick knows what Cuba is?
Uh well, he knows it's communist and he knows communism is bad.
So yes, he does know what Cuba is. insulate myself
and then lie when people ask about it.
Uh This guy said lying is Yeah, he did say this is the guy who
said lying is okay. Yeah. >> appreciated the shout-out.
Lying is okay. Can we just mention how dumb it is that we're
implying the government is in the business of giving hotels their
star
>> Um this is a five-star hotel. Hotel Playa Cayo. Hasan
says that Ethan Klein loves starving innocents. Dude, could you
imagine a person who loved The Leftovers podcast? If you go back
3 years and you send just the first beginning part of this tweet,
Hasan [__] says that Ethan Klein loves starving innocents.
I mean, I wouldn't have said that the first time, but clearly
now we're two for two on bad decisions for Ethan, right? I would
never have said, just based on only his support for Israel, that
he loves starving innocents. Although you could say it there.
But now he's on the wrong side of the issue a second time.
He He's now supporting the starving of innocents for a second
time. So what am I supposed to say? Seems like two lines Sorry,
two points, that makes a line. We got a trend. I can't believe
this is still going, bro. Yeah, how far have we come on this
story? How [__] far How How How far have we fallen?
Um
that liberals are only criticizing what went down in Cuba cuz
he was there. These people have no vision Hasan said lying Yeah,
I know Destin Suggs. I know. I know.
I know he said lying is okay because people were lying about
him. Well, technically a little bit funny cuz he was I believe
talking about the shock collar, okay? And he said lying is okay.
But he was implying they were lying about him and their lying
was overpowered. Yes. vision or goals out of politics. They're
purely reactionary in their policies politics revolve around
opposing me. I wish them well.
Holy Christ, these are all melting down over people delivering
aid to Cuba. He loves starving innocents. Why are liberals mad
at the flotilla?
I know why they're actually mad. I was wondering what excuse
they were going to use to be mad. It's cuz I went. These people
have no vision or goals I wish I seriously wish it wasn't that
simple.
I really do. I like actually wish it wasn't just that simple
that these people literally hate this flotilla and they're so
against it just because Hasan [__] went. But that
is actually it. That's it. Can he not pronounce Is he saying
flotilla?
>> Wait, hold on. That's unironically what we thought about
Qlenn earlier. That was the the joke about Qlenn.
Is it like Is That's what they wrap my burrito in, right? A flotilla
shell? A flo- a flotilla shell? Yeah?
He can't not think about food. What the out of politics, dude.
Please don't tell me They have no vision. They just go out in
the stream and say stuff. They're purely reactionary. Their politics
revolve around opposing me. It sounds insane, but that's a big
reason I Dude, he's coping so hard, bro.
These people
Dude, the Hasan is bad stuff is so free for these guys every
time they do it. They didn't check into anything and they're
all humiliating themselves
Okay, now listen. I was talking to Qlenn last night and he was
like I was like, "Dude." He was telling me how the content's
dry. There's no content out here, okay?" He was telling me this.
I'm like, "Bro, just go cover the Cuba stuff." Like I know I
know he doesn't like doing it cuz it's it's like pretty easy,
but these people are they're debasing themselves.
Like this is this is by far the most egregious like pro-H3 propaganda
Nick has ever done. It's embarrassing.
You got to cover it, man. You got to cover it, dog. This is good
stuff. What is flotilla? I don't know. It's dude, it's so cringe.
It's so What is flotilla? What is flotilla? I don't even know.
It's so cringe, man.
What is flotilla? Well, I don't even know. Well, I don't even
know what a flotilla is. That's like what they wrap my burrito
What else we got?
Oh my god. Here, banger meme. This is the one that Zander Hall
pushed. Cyber Boy says annual
average annual salary in Cuba, 156
Dude, every single
I swear to god, every single red flag Nicholas has like plot
armor. Every single red flag the gods can throw up to him that
he's on the wrong side of this, he's taking as encouragement.
Layla Sapientis is the only person clipping your only person
clipping Hasan. You're taking all your talking points from her.
Nick, run. Nick, run. Qlenn and Harley debasing themselves further
than you are stealing all of your viewers. Nick, run. Nick, they
suck. Nick, run.
Hey, um You're on the same side as Zander Hall right now. Zander
Hall is agreeing with you. Nick, here's a thousand red flags,
Nick. Run. Run, Nick.
But he can't see them. Can't see it at all. US Hasan Piker's
glasses,
1,000
Sorry, I got a I got an email from Twitch and I said, "No! Don't
No, not my Twitch account." We're
I mean, that's just funny. I'm sorry. You realize that insurance
for glasses exists, right? Oh, suck a fat. Suck a fat one, dude.
Holy sh
Uh I'm loath to commit to comment on what is functionally celebrity
gossip, but does he Oh god, I just noticed
I just noticed he dropped to 2,000 viewers instead of 3,000.
I thought he was ending the stream, but did he just go to content
that wasn't
Oh no, he didn't end the stream. Okay, he did end the stream.
He didn't do another segment. Never mind, he was ending the stream.
He was ending the stream. Okay, we're fine. We're fine. We're
fine. Bro, I was like, "Dude, there's no way he dropped off that
hard, right?" Well, he kind of did covering the Nisa stuff. >> Truly feel
no shame whatsoever.
Oh my god, dude. Yeah, he's in a Telling him to run is fat phobic.
five-star hotel hotel wearing $1,300 glasses. And I don't know
if I have the picture here, but they caught this guy they caught
this guy wearing Dude, they're This guy he's claiming it's a
600 They caught this guy
on a trip where he was filming. They caught him.
They caught him on a trip where he was filming.
They We got him, guys. We got him. They caught him out here filming
talking to Cubans or something. We got him. We got him, guys.
>> Dude, a $690
button-down, $1,300
glasses, and a
Cartier ring. Isn't that the shirt he wore on stream? Did he
wear that Is he wearing that shirt on one of the streams? This
guy is walking around with more money than these people will
will ever see in their entire lives. >> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> awful. I'm willing to fight on this one. >> Yeah, he
is wearing it. Hold on. Where is this? He's wearing it right
How do I do this? Hold on. Oh, it's still live. I can't I actually
put this He was wearing it right >> it better as a bracelet
than as a They caught him, guys. but I can't get in the picture.
That's so funny. But dude, he has to wear an Apple Watch because
if he wears a Rolex or a Patek or like a
or like a Royal Oak or something, they'll just say that he's
Ethan Klein. He is unwatchable. He cannot wear a designer He's
not a designer, but he cannot wear a horologically significant
timepiece or they'll just say he's Ethan Klein, so he has to
buy a horologically significant timepiece.
I'll be honest, I got no idea what that means. He just used some
language I am unaware of.
Damn. Every other piece of
Guys, Hasan is so cringe because he spends way too much on on
what on everything on clothes on
Also, he can't even spend that much on a watch cuz he sucks cuz
he'd be copying Ethan. Dude, what? Dude, what? God his head is
small.
Oh my god, dude. That's so funny. That's so funny, dude.
Dude, look at this car. I honestly, you could probably sell that
car for less than the ring that Hasan is wearing to this impoverished
country.
And And by the way, the fact that this guy is wearing like three
grand at any given moment Dude, it's It's so funny. What would
they do if Hasan dressed like the people there?
What would they do?
Oh my god, he said
He's like trying to pretend he's poor. I
I just want I want somebody's rules. What are the rules for Hasan
so I can watch them shift the second Hasan starts starts following
them at any point. I I got to see what the rules for Hasan is
from any of these guys, man. >> went on this trip is exactly
why he's staying at a five-star hotel.
I mean,
We're going after a guy for having cool things. That's fine.
But don't you kind of think it's a little bit significant that
this guy's got like thousands and thousands of dollars of
clothing and then he just happened to show up at a five-star
hotel and had 50 different reasons on why he's there.
I mean, I'm I'm I'm Listen, it's it's an opinion at the end of
the day. I can't prove this, but
I think it makes a lot of sense why he's staying at a five-star
hotel in a country that he's never been to before if he's decided
to bring Cuz he went with a group of people who booked it and
Dude, there's like a million different reasons that this would
be the case.
>> of is like That's actually painful. >> hype merch
And if he said that honestly, if he turned around Cuz now we
need to see the Ethan Klein reaction to Hasan
wearing expensive stuff. Let's go. >> down in sand Here
it is. >> Hey, listen, I have like a certain aesthetic
and I'm going to continue wearing all this stuff and having all
this stuff and bring it with me even if I've never been to this
country before and it's like a potential hostile to US territory
and all this stuff. Uh and I don't know how it's going to go
or whatever. So, I'm staying at like a better hotel. Honestly,
I would be okay with I don't know if I'd be okay with it. I'd
probably still poke fun at him, but it's more pathetic that he's
like lying about it.
You know, if he was open about it, it would be a bit of a different
story.
Ethan [snorts] Klein's uh stories that we were showing before
are some of some of them are here. I applaud this man's bravery.
He flew from LA to Miami first class and endured a 30-minute
flight on coach, stayed one night in a five-star
made tens of thousands of dollars
the whole ordeal, and was back in time for March Madness. Dude,
What Is there a joke there? He didn't even read the last line.
Dude, he's literally This is literally a
I don't know what to call it other than a minstrel show for like
H3. Like it's it's actually
total debasement of everything you stood for. You're humiliating
yourself. You're laughing at his jokes. You're You're like yucking
it up at his jokes, but there isn't even a joke. You didn't even
read to the punchline.
flight on coach, stayed one night in a five-star hotel,
made tens of thousands of dollars
the whole ordeal, and was back in time for March Madness. He
didn't even the The punchline is a true socialist icon. It wasn't
the March Madness line.
He's like out of breath halfway through this, too. >> stayed
one night in a five-star hotel,
made tens of thousands of dollars strea-
Listen to the intake.
hotel in one night in a five-star hotel,
made tens of thousands of dollars
the whole ordeal, and was back in time for March Madness. Totally
totally fake
Bro, I Where Where's
Where's Smegel at? That's what I got to know. Where's Smegel
at? Okay? Someone find me Smegel now and make him watch this
on repeat until he disavows Nicholas De Oreo entirely, okay?
Where the is Smegel?
Where the [__] is anybody who stood behind him? Where's
Augie? Where's I want Augie. Augie, open your eyes, Augie. Augie,
open your eyes.
Help this guy before he before it's too
What in the [__] is occurring here? >> made
tens of thousands of dollars
the whole ordeal, and was back in time for March Madness. Help
Help him. Help him. He's in pain. Help him. Did you know he once
considered going to Gaza? Oh
>> Oh my god. Wait.
Dude, that was actually too soon. I spoke too soon. Oh god, I
spoke too soon. What? He laughs here.
Did you know he once considered going to Gaza? Dude, he's doing
Did he listen to my impression of him? My minstrel show impression?
He's actually doing the laugh.
What? you know he once considered going to Gaza? These dumb
Bro, he's actually
Dude, my voice is also so I can barely do the bit now, which
sucks cuz this is the perfect night to do the bit. But my voice
is too for me to hit like the up the rising thing. So,
I wish it was I wish it was better, okay? But I swear to god,
that's like the exact
That's the exact laugh. >> went to Cuba to throw a rave
for themselves with the last drops of oil on the island.
>> Bouncy castle slides for Cuba. Don't worry, everyone,
they painted a mural.
Okay, I didn't see any of this This is absolutely outrageous.
Ethan's popping off. You know, the dichotomy Ethan Klein mercilessly
abusing De Oreo's throat. It's actually [__] up.
Bro, you couldn't even find this video on a regular site. You'd
have to go to some crazy off off the clear web site to watch
this video. Nicholas is is being abused so badly right now. Disgusting.
You hate to see it. I can't even do the sounds, man. I can't
even do the sounds.
Absolutely crazy. Let's continue. >> really me up. Sips
from a tiny espresso cup. Hasan walked briskly back to his five-star
hotel knowing that the room service stopped at 8:00 p.m. There
was a filet mignon that he was eyeing that would go a long way
towards his daily goal of 300 g of protein. This is crazy. This
is crazy. Ruin Leon said, "To be fair, I wouldn't have missed
March Madness, either." I Dude, absolutely
Ethan Klein's sword, okay? Ethan Klein's not so Nazi sword, all
right? Very kosher sword. He's absolutely polishing
Holy sh And the other thing that happened there was there was
like a countrywide blackout while he was streaming from his generated
five-star hotel. And if he picked anywhere else, he wouldn't
have had his show. Um Denim says that Twitch streamer Hasan should
send a retraction letter to the New York Post for calling his
trip to China sponsored propaganda. Do we have that? Yes, we
do. Yes, we do. We don't look at legacy media in the year of
2026.
Heart-pounding audio Oh, there was a plane crash. Sorry, that
wasn't supposed to be here. Tone-deaf radicals flock to Havana
staying in a five-star hotel while island in crisis mockery of
the Cuban people from the New York Post.
Uh hundreds of tone-deaf
lefty radicals flock to Havana this weekend to meet with the
Communist Party officials staying in luxury hotels traveling
in air-conditioned buses as the rest of the island grapples with
a worsening economic crisis that starved of electricity, food,
water, and medicine. The Nutresa American convoy sent out socialists
from America and Europe to Cuba by air, sea, and land under the
guise of handing out 20 tons of humanitarian aid to protest the
United States oil blockade on Cuba.
Dude, [snorts] these guys get mad at like Dude, these guys get
mad at Taylor Swift for flying and they literally sent a squad
of socialists
probably without any deodorant to a foreign country to have a
party. Yeah. The convoy includes
Dude, that's your That's your takeaway.
That's your takeaway right there? There's no way. There's no
way that's your takeaway, right? Just Just totally
totally drips over the actual embargo
Onto Hasan's back. Dude, it's They probably don't even have deodorants.
Mayors Jama Damis ally and influential streamer Hasan [__]
who recently went on Beijing sponsored propaganda trip. That's
the thing that Denims is mad about. To Havana from where he broadcasted
to 1.6 million Instagram followers Saturday with somehow spotless
internet connection. I think this is a lie. That's slander. The
internet connection was not spotless and promised to film content.
Is era Hursty, 23-year-old unemployed activist daughter
of embattled
embattled squad
Okay, this is this is a bit of a struggle for me. Also taking
part of the voyage is a delegation of Madami's
Embattled squad rep Ilhan Omar, Democrat Minnesota, is also taking
part in the voyage. Socialist American comrades
and then she's more going through everyone who was there. Some
delegates reportedly staying at the five-star Grand Hotel Bristol
Melia Court Collection where rooms cost between 130 and 520 dollars
a night. Others posed for pictures
Dude, have you guys stayed in a hotel that's 130 dollars a night?
It's like not even nice in the states.
Like the the cost of whatever this is Dude, this is so cheap.
Riding in comfy air-conditioned buses and meeting with President
Miguel Diaz-Canel
at pas- something something Spanish-sounding Cuba Cuba Cuba Havana.
Cuban officials reported an island-wide blackout this week. Yeah,
that was a thing that happened. In the embattled community nation
of some 11 million people after President Trump and Community
nation, eh?
You think he hates the people so much, you think he'd understand
that the word is communist. You think you know the word is communist.
embattled community nation of some
Uh-huh. thing that happened. In the embattled community nation
of some 11 million people after President Trump in January threatened
tariffs to any nation selling oil choking off its energy supply
while nearly the entire country is suffering from power outages
lasting over 20 hours. The left is welcome with air conditioning
and wasteful
consumption
slammed Mira Dominguez, a Cuban living in exile in the United
States. More than 100 Not somebody in Cuba.
Dude, the hammering on the air conditioning point is really funny
to me. Your homes wouldn't be without power today if Castro's
regime didn't spend on the communist propaganda with the international
leftists.
Yeah, this is just Dude, this is crazy. This is absolutely insane.
One of the
Dude, this is like This is unironically like opening up, you
know, some Fox News opinion piece and just repeating everything
uncritically.
It's Why Why would you do like right-wing Why would you do right-wing
propaganda on your stream for free?
Well, I guess not for free. He's getting paid a lot, but Jesus.
It's actually crazy
to watch this. Nations and organizations
Is there anything important here? No.
After causing more than a million Cubans to leave in just five
years in denying many the right to return to their own country,
they're now open to foreigners
humani- foreign humanitarian
Cuban artist Salome Garcia who lives in exile in Miami blasted
on Facebook.
And these are the people they were getting mad at on the way
there. Like Hasan was complaining about Miami Cubans saying they're
like the like the worst. Dude, this is a crazy image, too. Like
they're all just on a comfy air-conditioned bus. I think this
is their plane though, no?
>> Dude, he's like he's like just read There's some script
that is had he's reading off of. He's not paying attention. He's
like, "Wait, did I just say that? Wait, no, this is the plane
though." Bro, what's the other voice in your head that's doing
your show for you that you had to just wake up? You had to become
conscious there in the middle of your own stream to go, "Wait,
no, that's wrong, Nicholas. That's like the plane." Dude, what
just happened?
Like they're all just You guys think they got some get-out set
up over there in California? Nick actually went and they trapped
him, okay? They did the whole teacup thing. They trapped him
in the sunken place. He's actually He's actually totally mind
raped right now, okay? That was him breaking out. Whoa, no, actually
I think that's an airplane.
The air-conditioned bus. Air-conditioned bus. comfy air-conditioned
bus. I think this is their plane though, no? Yeah, that's hilarious.
What is crazy? It's crazy work. Couldn't Guys, don't Nobody's
saying we don't read legacy media. One, it's the New York Post.
It's basically a tweet, okay? They They rarely have paragraphs
more than three sentences long. Two, you could barely get through
the like what? 50% of the article? And
you couldn't read a bunch of words in the article.
He said
I crazy work.
The convoy I can see why he doesn't read stuff. I can see why
he stays uninformed. includes Mayor Zoran Mamdani ally and influential
streamer Hasan [__] who recently went on a Beijing
sponsored trip. Wow.
Dude, he should issue a retraction statement to the New York
Post. It wasn't sponsored. Dude, it wasn't sponsored. He just
really loves sucking China's Guys, Yes. Yes. China is I'll put
this in language you can understand. China is to Hasan [__]
as Ethan Klein is to you. Yes. He loves
Yes, he does.
Everyone thinks he's sponsored because it literally would have
to be sponsored, but it wasn't sponsored. Dude, Mayor Zoran Mamdani
ally and He just loves China that much. influential streamer
Hasan Dude, does that mean he loves China and hates gay dating
apps? I don't know. [__] recently went on a Beijing
sponsored trip. Wow.
Dude, he should issue a retraction statement. Oh, he's 100% mud
hard maxing. Yeah, he's either he's either off or he works like
reduced hours or he works like spot hours or something. Yeah,
100%.
100% he's doing this stuff full-time. Or it's it's possible he's
worked it in so he's got like a script ready to go and like a
script ready that's written for him. And he's got like an editor
who puts everything together and he basically just shows up and
reads the script and goes to work the next day. That would be
disastrous for his career. Right? This is the thing that makes
way more money. He should obviously focus on this. But maybe
maybe that's what's happening. Maybe that explains why he's not
actually prepped or why he doesn't understand anything about
any of the [__] he's talking about. Maybe that's
what's happening. It wasn't
I'm [snorts] just saying like what is her win condition? If he
went there and it wasn't sponsored by China or if China did not
like reach out and ask him to do it.
Wouldn't that make it worse if he just did it for free? literally
an untrue statement. He should actually issue Also, this is a
crazy clip of Denims. There's no low-cut top. She's not reacting
to something and she's speaking. This is like a rare form for
her. a retraction demand to the New York Post to Havana from
where he broadcasted to his This is her one position per show,
yeah. 1.6 million Instagram followers Saturday with a somehow
spotless internet connection. Spotless. Okay, I agree with Denims
here. Full full stop. Full I got to give a I'm calling a spade
a spade. The spotless internet connection is slander.
Spotless internet connection.
Meanwhile, all of chat is
L F F F F F
women may not be fast enough to race it with men at the Olympics,
but they are certainly fast enough to race Nicholas De Orio Kil
okay and put some respect on their name, all right? The average
women could outrace Nicholas, all right? Unless it was downhill.
Can you make In which case, no human can outrace Nicholas, okay?
better? Can you make the stream better? Ha Hasan Hasan's stream
move my wording, but but no, don't sleep. Okay, this is weird.
What is Denims doing? Denims is not doing a baby voice, is she?
I'm
What the [__] the internet better? Can you make the
stream better? Ha Hasan Hasan's stream move my wording, but but
no, don't sleep.
All right, I can't do any more of this. Sorry, can't listen to
any more denims. And Bro.
She's doing Ela voice? No.
She's doing like a baby voice. She's literally doing like a baby
voice right
That was like a
There's like three Oilers that she knows really like that voice,
okay? That has to be That has to be what's going on. I was doing
like a slobbering voice, Cosmo. That was a baby voice she was
doing. I don't do baby voice. I do
Don't know what's going on over here. It's like a slobbering
Trillian, okay? That's way different.
Ethan then shouts out to Hasan drinking espresso and Xpyker to
show off. Lucas, Lucas, I can confirm you're a Queen Man guy,
right? Just making sure cuz Queen Man tries to tell me that he
doesn't have any D Gen viewers, but I definitely clocked you
as a Queen Man viewer, okay? Lucas Jay sent it. I know you are.
I know, okay? his hotel room. You couldn't write this better
with the little sip. And someone asked him to show the room,
presidential suite, government mandated five-star hotel. I was
saying tourism is the lifeline for the Cuban economy as it stands
currently. So we've seen this clip, right? >> comparison
to the If I I mean not ever, but like I I hope to come back and
when I do, I'll probably
not abide by Such a funny clip. >> any American restrictions.
I was saying >> The fourth time we're watching this, Oh,
yeah, this is the the but this is the tweet that I said Queen
Man should edit one of his videos in here with little espresso
cup. So good. me up.
Definitely. Someone asked him to show us his room in the presidential
suite. Well, you thought we're to ever If I I mean not ever,
but like I I hope to come back and when I do, I'll probably Sorry,
it's a bit crowded, I know.
>> I don't think that's the You Dude, dude, what? I I hope
to come back. That's so good. Sorry, it's a bit crowded, I know.
>> I don't think that's the US forced me to stay here,
by the way. I would have chosen a tent on the back streets of
Nevada, I swear. Hold on. I wonder if I've gotten to this point
yet.
Someone sent me Someone sent me a clip here of
of Nicholas. I don't think we got to this yet. Apparently, we
haven't even heard the worst
forced the Oreo laugh yet.
Apparently, we haven't even gotten there
I think.
Can't tell when this is from. Whatever, we keep going.
Breaking fake stats about Ethan Klein. I don't really care about
this, but somebody tweeted that Ethan posted 800 plus Instagram
stories in 3 months. I don't think that's accurate. I I I would
be shocked if I did that's 800 on Hasan [__] exclusively
is kind of insane. But then Hasan just quote tweeted the random
account saying that.
I don't know. Oh. Not really a significant thing, but it's kind
of crazy that he just dove into that headfirst cuz I guarantee
Hasan wouldn't know either. Twitch streamer Hasan [__]
describes his interactions with YouTube vlogger Nas
Dude, he let Nas down. At the Havana airport when he was leaving
Cuba. Hasan states that Nas Daily, Nuseir Yassin, was a was freaking
people out and making them uncomfortable at the airport during
the confrontation.
Hasan recalls challenging Nas when Nas was saying that Hasan
was ruining
Wait, is this the guy who went after
Is this the guy from the content nuke?
is it somebody else?
No, this isn't money and gambling,
I don't know who Nas Daily is. Hasan demands that Nas Daily is
releasing the entire recording of their confrontation at the
airport.
Outside the clip, Hasan accuses Israel of sending their agents
out to confront
Not dating and money. Why did I think it was money and gambling?
Dude, dating and money's slogan I'm waiting to see if Nicholas
will
accidentally like without checking just accuse Hasan of blaming
the for everything here. He's being He's being very tempered
on this. Money and
>> I don't know why I just I saw a Kick streamer and immediately
guessed that they were I'm trying to do
He said money and gambling. That's I'm sorry. Holy dude.
Apparently, there's more to this clip, so we got a decent chunk
here. This is the drama on the way home from Cuba. Decent work.
Nas Daily has built his career whitewashing Israel's genocide
of Palestinians and Azerbaijan's ethnic cleansing of Armenians.
Now he's agitating on behalf of America to violently destroy
Cuba, right? Um Also, during this entire thing, wasn't Badempanada
making tweets where I assume he'll claim he was joking like talking
about like
you know, like [clears throat] something Hasan I obviously just
Badempanada went to Cuba and he kept tweeting over and over again,
I'm flying to Cuba to kill Hasan [__] I've landed
in Cuba in Cuba. I will find Hasan [__] and kill
him. He was tweeting this constantly,
okay? Well, he doesn't want to He doesn't want to get banned.
They were insane. Okay. Now, I'm going to be
Somebody linked me Badempanada's video from Cuba. He's already
got it out.
And I know this sounds insane,
but the video's actually kind of good. I watched like 10 minutes
of it. It was actually like a good video like an impressively
good video for how quick the turnaround was.
It's literally just him walking around with a Cuban guy talking
about that Cuban guy growing up in Cuba and how it shifted from
like the Soviet Union being there to the Soviet Union falling
and then being under blockade.
It was just him doing like interviews like street interviews
with people cuz he's he's from Latin America, right? So he speaks
Spanish really well.
He's just like going around talking to people. It was like actually
a good video from what I saw. It might have gotten crazy afterwards.
It was just funny to me.
No, he's from Australia? Well, he speaks Spanish fluently, so
he sure looks like he's from the like Central America or something,
but hey, who am I to say? Yeah, no, he he did a really good job
in this video and I was just shocked cuz I was like I I clicked
on it cuz I was like, oh, it'll be funny. Maybe he like maybe
he was Hasan somehow. I don't think he's really going to kill
Hasan, but maybe [__] with Hasan somehow, maybe do
some drama. And then it's just like a very serious
I was like, what? Huh? Okay. Dude, it was it was very funny,
man. I was like I was getting ready for drama and then it was
just him talking to some Cuban guy about the like the bread
Wow, that but I saw that recently. His attack dogs The bait and
switch was
You know, he was saying that he was going to Yeah, ooh. Yeah.
He was in Cuba, too? Oh my god. Where is it? So, he came up to
me at the Havana Dude, I In case you guys didn't know that he
likes Cuba, he made sure to wear the biggest Cuba hat he had.
airport while I was flying
to Mexico and then flying to Los Angeles to enter the country
through Los Angeles. Bro, this guy's going to get some weird
Dr. House thing.
Flying through Dude, from Cuba to Mexico. Dude, that's the first
thing they ask you when you go to like the doctor, they're like,
have you been to Have you been like out of the country in I don't
know, like any Cuban or Mexican locations recently? Yesterday.
I was
I didn't fully know who he Dude, this is some Brandon Buckingham
like Wait, I know it was a button reference, but I just don't
know I don't know if he could like hit the button actually and
have it like cancel out the last little bit of his stream. I
don't know if he runs a feed like that. I understand the button
reference for sure. I was shocked. I didn't fully know who he
Dude, this is some Brandon Buckingham like he just didn't mention
was when he approached me yelling with a phone camera in tow
with his girlfriend,
right? And he was like, oh, do you know me? I'm Nas Daily. Do
you know me? I'm Nas Daily. I'm like, what the [__]
I turn around.
This [__] Dude, Lil Nas X is standing right behind
me. What the [__] Guy. You got into rehab when?
He's like, do you know me? I'm Nas Daily. I have a massive
Dude, I'm trying to think of how much more I want to cover here.
What else do I have on the docket today? Let me see Let me see
what else I got. I got some Anisa stuff.
Do Trump Aspen gold. I can probably just cover this. It's like
pretty funny.
Let me see. I think we just keep going with this. To be honest,
I'm going to keep going. I I might go back to some politics after
depending on how much time we got on the clock. I have a massive
YouTube channel.
And when he realized Check this video out for 1 minute.
Let's go.
Well, we could just watch this after,
One of the most ridiculous embargoes of all time on Cuba has
only gotten more deadly as time has gone on. Move over Sophocles.
Two words, useful idiots, okay? Useful idiots to the regime.
Pinkos to you know, [laughter] you know, typical. [clears throat]
He's wearing a $1,500 Cartier sunglasses, okay? While the people
cannot eat in Cuba and if they speak out like this guy is, they'd
be thrown in jail with no no redress. This is absurd. And all
these humanitarian radicals, Laura, are staying at five-star
hotels.
Dude, what?
What? The Cubans are starving and enduring blackouts. Rather
than making those glittery hearts, they should have spent the
craft money on maybe feeding these people and shut their mouths.
This is not what freedom looks like what Cuba is offering their
people. This is suppression and oppression and it's gone on for
for decades now. Time to wrap this up. Wow. So cool.
This is just like This is just like
It's like half of the liberals I know on Twitter right here doing
this exact
It's very funny. Stop oppression? I don't know I think he's trying
to say suppression. So is oppression? It's so oppression? Dude,
it's crazy just watching I
I don't know who else does this like Hasan right now who's just
like so powerful people will drop their principles entirely just
to be like, this guy actually sucks. Wait, you took solar panels
to this country that doesn't have power cuz of an American blockade?
Uh Actually, you killed people. Yeah, you killed people.
No, we took them like additional power generator No, you killed
people.
You're like a murderer. You like you like killed people.
No, what? >> Hassan, since we're in Ca- Anyway, sorry.
We I want to go back to New York a little. >> idea who
he was. He started immediately yelling about >> go viral?
I didn't even see this clip. I I've only seen the clip of his
Wait, Hassan did that? Hassan was a part of the group that did
that. Yeah.
Hassan was literally in the group of people. They they came together,
they organized this thing together.
I'm assuming they brought people for like different reasons,
right? That like they're they're saying, "Hey Hassan, you should
come cuz that will get eyes on the trip. That will get eyes on
this whole thing, right?" You know,
He's for Hassan talking about it knowing exactly who he is. or
Hamas. We're in Havana, Cuba. Okay? We're at the Havana >> Dude,
breaking news. YouTuber who's extremely controversial is controversial
in places that he wouldn't expect. >> What? And he just
starts screaming about Hamas and Israel. He's like, "I'm Palestinian
and what you're doing is hurting the Palestinians."
And I was like, "The [__] are you talking about?"
Right? >> And everyone stood up and clapped. Yeah. And
then
This was when you were leaving or arriving? No, this Hey Andrew,
thank you. I appreciate you. I'm kind of black pilled on this
[__] Hell yeah.
How is it
taking aid to Cuba is hurting >> Hassan is so bad at mimicking
the way humans tell stories. >> Yeah, I know.
No, I was leaving. This is when I was leaving. He's one of the
bad Palestinians?
There's no way that guy Dude, I remember
Remember John Swan? Remember these guys? Remember Beau Blacks?
Remember Beau This guy is just like Beau Blacks and Flamenco
and John Swan. Remember them?
Okay? Is that true?
Hassan knew him. Well, anytime I hear a >> That's that's
how you actually tell a story, okay? You never introduce new
elements. You only you know, once a year you add like one new
element of maybe 15 to your repertoire. You just never otherwise
never tell different stories. You just keep running the same
[__] back over and over again. >> People say
like I've never heard of this person before, eight out of 10
times they know exactly who it is and that was a pre-scripted
thing that they wanted to say. Hassan [__] is literally
known for the Isn't this the guy that for a person he's already
spoken about with the like past calendar year? I found it very
strange that an agent of Israel was also in Cuba. Up, the Jews
are coming after me again. Right? All these dude all these the
Jews are they're just attacking me. I knew he'd get there. I
knew he'd get there eventually, okay? And there were these wonderful
older people
that were also Dude, three years ago if you said an agent of
Israel is coming after me, everyone would ostracize you from
the group. I was sitting at this cafe. Just just casually dropping
that. Okay, what if this guy is like paid by Israel, Nick? Would
you say it's fair to call him a agent of Israel?
If this guy were literally paid by Israel, would it be like just
would be anti-Semitism? Would it Would you be a Jew hater for
pointing out that that guy was a literal agent of Israel? Wavy,
when we go to VidCon, do you think any agents of Israel are going
to [__] us up?
Sorry, I can't go to that party. I hear there's going to be agents
of Israel attending. the airport next to us and they were so
grossed out by this >> Wait a minute. VidCon is in California.
The official agents of Israel are going to be there. [__]
freak speak. >> Then one of the ladies was like, "Hey,
can I ask you You just realized the hat. How?
>> It's It's extremely subtle. Some people might miss the
the detail that
"What What do you do that like this person is yelling >> just
say that? I just noticed the Like I noticed the hat, dude. Hey,
what's going on? I was like, "Yeah, I'm you know, I'm a pro-Palestinian
political commen-
And he just like was screaming. He just got like more and more
agitated.
Right? He got more and more >> This did not happen. I mean,
I could imagine it did happen. I don't know. >> agitated
because I wasn't giving him the attention that he desperately
wanted. This It's probably like 5% true. It probably did happen,
just not the way that he said. Again, this guy his his entire
position is that lying is a powerful resource, right? So, I can't
really take any of this at face value. You're going to have to
have receipts on top of receipts for that.
Man, they just keep reusing that, eh? Bunch of people Hassan
says a bunch of people are lying about him and that lying is
OP.
Oh, you're saying lying is OP? That means you lie a lot, right?
No. No.
Uh I turned around. You got any of that
I don't know. Does Cuba's airports have security cameras? Do
we have footage of that? around.
I turned around.
And I said, "Do you feel like this is making you look good?"
Dude, so that's when I turned around, looked him in the eyes
and I'm like, "Do you think that you look good right now?" And
then the whole chat's like, "Oh! Yo! No way, bro. He didn't just
say that. He did. He did." "Do you feel like you're getting a
good clip out of this? You're freaking out all of these people
around us." Dude, this is cringe as And that's what I said, "Hey
man, you mad, bro?" And the entire room was just like, "No way!
He made me experience high tide."
I used to be able to do that way better. And I think that was
a moment of of self-reflection for him cuz he kind of stopped
and his girlfriend was like embarrassed, right? His girlfriend
was a little bit
>> Dude, I could tell when he was sitting there chastising
me that his girlfriend was just disgusted by him. So, he
He stopped filming. We didn't film it. March was next to me.
>> Dude, Hassan was watching this in bullet time. Like
he was in slow motion and in mentally writing down every single
aspect of this. Why? What What this Dude, there's no way he's
going to become like more and more performative as the view count
goes down.
You guys think Do you guys I feel like that's going to happen.
Like as the view count goes down, he's going to get more and
more aggressive in this performance. He's going to get like worse
and worse in how much he exaggerates stuff. Like over and over
Dude, it's It's It is Yeah, it's like a wound It Dude, it's rubbed
all tells me is he was thinking about this the entire flight
home that he could remember this so vividly. Um we didn't give
a [__] enough to
How many times did Nick tell the story about his glasses getting
taken? Titties, that's crazy mirror posting. That's insane mirror
posting, man. Dude, Hassan's talking about this guy who confronted
him. He's been thinking about this the whole way home. Dude,
okay. How many times have you told the same story about your
glasses getting taken, bro? to film it. Right? So,
And then the entire airport stopped, looked at me and then clapped.
And they actually elected me their king.
Did Hassan Did Hassan call this guy a slur, do you think, Nick?
Do you think this guy could have like been really edgy and cool
and called this guy a
What do you think? What do you think? Do you think he Do you
think he did that? That would be really cool. Wouldn't that be
a really cool thing to do?
And I told him, "No, no. I'm a socialist, all right? That's not
what we do here." He went away. And I I Hold on. Did I close
the prediction?
Hold on.  prediction. I didn't close it. He It was doesn't
condemn. The doesn't condemn people won, but people knew that.
Okay. I I think I paid it out. >> I thought that was the
end of that
But we were leaving uh the the cafe to go to our gate.
But it turns out >> Can I say something to you, Nick? >> end
there. He wanted more. He wanted a better clip cuz he couldn't
get it, So, he was filming from afar and yelling still. "You
You're going to stop doing Hamas propaganda. You're going to
do You're going to stop doing >> Dude, again, the way to
handle this is like, "Hey, there was some crazy freak at the
airport. He was like screaming. It was like really embarrassing.
Uh I I hope you enjoyed the clip if he posted it online. If he
didn't, then that just shows he's like a loser." doing Hamas
propaganda. You need to stop >> Like there's nothing personal
about this. There's no reason to get into detail on this.
Like I I I don't know. Like does he think this helps him with
like the the Hamas stuff or like the exposing Israel's agents
or something? and supporter of Hamas. Yeah. Yeah,
Probably just like him calling out a guy who's paid by Israel
for like going to Cuba just to harass him while they're on an
aid trip. Makes people who are Makes him if he's like just a
contractor, makes him look really shitty. And if he's getting,
you know, if he's working for some specific department there
or something along those lines,
then it makes that whole like I don't know, whatever body that
guy is a part of look bad. Yeah. That's probably the goal. >> "You're
hurting the Palestinian cause. You're hurting the Palestinian
cause." That's when I, you know, experienced a maybe a blip of
cortisol spike.
So, I turned around and said, "What are you going to do about
it?" And that's when he his pants and cried. Yeah, I hear reports
say that he's he screamed, "Mommy, Mommy, Mommy" on his way out.
I didn't even drop my bag. Dude, Nick is so bad at snarking.
Dude, I could I could weave a way better narrative here. I can
already see Dude, I can already go in the other direction on
that. He just said, "What are you going to do about
You're going to stop me?" >> Nicholas De Orio streamed
about this last night and after watching Nick's stream, I'm kind
of black pilled on this POV, I chose speed in that one clip.
do about it?" Oh!
Actually true, though.
>> "Who going to stop me?" "Who going to stop me?" I didn't
even drop my bags. I just said, "What are you going to do about
it?" >> make me laugh. Hey, [laughter] that's a new That's
a new Nick reference. He has a reference on that one forever.
Oh my gosh. >> to stop me? And he walked up to me, still
filming.
I said, "What are you going to do?"
Go ahead.
And this didn't punch me in the face. Go ahead. Stop me.
his girlfriend realized that the situation was that >> Yeah,
I don't know. Like, what do they do in Cuba if you if you hit
hit somebody in the airport? Do they like grind you into oil
and use you to power the city? Like, what What I don't know what
the [__] they do over there, bro. Holy [__]
No, I'm I'm not with that, either. Escalating. She tried to pull
him off.
She was like, "Come on, let's stop. Whatever." They They make
you into fossil fuels.
So, we did.
Uh Were they in Cuba? No, they were in They were in Cuba.
He started backing away, and I said, "Yeah, that's what I thought."
We proceeded to go towards the gate. He came back again to yell
from afar. He came back again to yell from afar. Dude, stop.
Stop.
He came back again >> He came back again to yell from afar.
>> to yell from afar. >> He just said [laughter]
it again. To say, "Oh, yeah, keep running away." And so, I turned
around and said, "Suck my And that's it. That's the end of that
But of course, because he couldn't >> Dude, why did he
tell that whole story like that? >> get any of the clips
he wanted out of it. I know I know why he did it. I know exactly
why he did it. How does Nick not know how to weave the story
on this? It's actually kind of rough.
I think if I if I wanted to star Casson here, the story I'd go
with is that this guy said, "You're hurting the Palestinians."
And Casson didn't care about the Palestinians to say that he
doesn't want that to No, I'd never do that. He was like, "Why
don't you stop me then? Why don't you stop me from hurting the
Palestinians?" And Casson probably doesn't like how that clip
In his head, he he understands like what that looks like, what
he's saying, and he probably doesn't like that. So, he's like
telling the story now to get it out before the clip comes out.
Cuz if the clip comes out on its own, he doesn't want that to
happen, right?
Why don't you stop hurting the Palestinians? Well, why don't
you stop me from hurting Why why Why don't you stop me? Do something
about it, [__]
I think he probably was just mad. He doesn't want it to come
out that way, so he's telling the story first. That's pretty
obviously to me what's going on here, no? And you could make
that worse. You could make that You totally spin that into something.
But he's like too lazy to do that. He's I don't know. He's like
playing pinball or something on his computer while he's streaming.
He had the cope. Dude,
>> Casson Biker was at the airport, and they and dude,
three guys cornered him and said,
"What would you do if Israel killed
>> That's literally what happened Dude, Wavy, that's what
happened just now. He was at the airport, and three guys walked
Oh, somebody must have pointed out that it was just like Nick's
story from from that party. >> "What would you do if Israel
committed
because of your video?"
>> And he somehow made himself look like the loser. But
when I stopped >> there a video of this from the other
guy? I don't He connected it himself? He sure did. He sure did.
Have it. Is it Does anyone know where it is? him make an argument
about Some people see this and think central planning is a good
As he talked about, you know, the the lack of trash collection
born out of the oil blockade.
Um it's definitely Hold on. It's
It's definitely not positive for them, crap merchant. Not because
they'll be able to get the correct stories out or anything. Not
that they'll really be able to correct anything. But it is positive
in that it does actually make people aware of the blockade, and
that the blockade is the cause of the energy
Like, at least the New York Post had that in the story. Everybody
ignored it, but at least it was there. Dude, he sounds like Mike
threatening jocks in Stranger Things. Dude, the worst piece of
dialogue in all of season 5. What What the [__] was
that? Does any Actually hate this
screaming and weirding out guys. Sorry, I was We're getting through
He was on the ground and came up to me at the Havana airport
to scream and weird everyone
Was it a chat? Well, Wavy Web Surf was in chat. I do believe
he goes to VidCon with Wavy Web Surf most years, no? They're
close friends. So, Wavy Web Wavy Web Surf was talking in his
chat. I'm guessing that's what was going on is he was noticing
that that guy was mentioning this [__] to him. Or
maybe maybe Wavy connected it himself. I I didn't see it. I don't
know. Don't you know me? I'm Nas Daily. >> Do we have any
Nas Daily clip footage? Like, I Dude Dude, he's letting Nas down
right now by not posting the full clip. >> I have a massive
pro Is he calling his own story fake then? He's saying I don't
know. I don't know.
He's He's telling the story and and realizing that it's a story
maybe he shouldn't have told. I don't know what he's not connecting,
to be honest with
Yes, the whole line he's been going down is telling the story
is cringe and stupid, and that he's probably overembellishing
it, and then he connected his own story that I presume he doesn't
think is gay, cringe, or overembellished.
I don't Yeah, I don't know. profile. His girlfriend also felt
weirded out by his behavior. I hope he gets well soon. Super
confusing. >> Okay. To which apparently he responded with,
"As a Palestinian origin Muslim for hundreds of years, I wanted
to make it clear by the way Yeah, nobody Dude, this clip, as
far as I'm aware, just doesn't exist. Everyone in his replies
are like, "You're not a Palestinian. Shut the [__]
up. You're an agent of Israel." As a Palestinian origin Muslim
for a hundred >> Like, why is he pushing Is he jumping
to get out ahead of something?
Jesus.
That If If this clip doesn't get posted or hasn't been posted
yet, dude, Casson talks about his quarter's all spiking moment
with Nas Daily.
Uh March 1st, famous grifter Nas Daily speaks out. Ethan's favorite
propagandist harassed
What the [__] What do we and this harassed Okay,
wait.
What is How is he doing that?
Wait screenshot for more contact.
What do we have here?
I can't find it. It's not Nas made an AI video of Karl Marx that
is [__]
What What What
Um he replied Okay, yeah, I'm not seeing any videos of this.
For hundreds of years, I wanted to make it clear to you that
you're bad for the Palestinian cause and your activism is hurting
innocents and empowering terrorists. Palestinians want moderate
leaders to lead them to peace and coexistence. They don't want
you to lead them to another fight while you stay in five-star
hotels live streaming wearing Gucci. P.S. You are only strong
online. So, this is the comment I was just finding, but I can't
find anything else.
That's why Then I said, "Is that why Wait, was that the video?
Did he skip over the video?
Oh, wait. Is that it? Is that it? Where is this tweet from Casson?
Oh, no, he's really getting ahead of this. He's like, "This agent
of Israel was on the
Let me see. He got there eventually to what his story should
be.
That's crazy.
Where are we? >> It took forever. So, if I scroll forward,
I can't see the profile. It's too long here. Came back Came to
Cuba for the weekend, became a die-hard capitalist. And then
Casson goes, "Okay, good for him. This Israeli agent was on the
ground. He came up to me at the Havana airport to scream and
weird everybody out. People around were worried for his mental
health." Oh, good. Good old concern trolling. Looking forward
to see how he tries to chop up the video. Yeah, he's actually
nervous of this coming out. That's weird. He's really [__]
He's really trying to get ahead of this one. He kept saying,
Bro, he needed his chat or somebody in in Discord DMs to explain
like how you should be framing this if you hate Casson. >> Don't
you know me? I'm Nas Daily. I have a massive profile. His girlfriend
felt weirded out by his behavior. I hope he gets well soon. Yeah,
that's weird. That's a weird thing. To which apparently he responded
with, "As a Palestinian origin Muslim for hundreds of years,
I wanted to make it clear by the way everyone in his replies
are like, "You're not a Palestinian. Shut the [__]
up. You're an Dude, wait. Wait, what? So, he goes Wait. As a
Palestinian, they're like, "No, dude, you're a [__]
You're a What is it? Like, a a spiritual Is that what they're
going for there? For hundreds of years, I wanted to make it clear
to No, like a paid agent of Israel, a paid propagandist for his
That's the Palestinian cause. Your activism is hurting innocents
and empowering terrorists. Palestinians want moderate leaders
to lead them to peace and coexistence. They don't want you to
lead them to another fight Okay. That's why Then I said, Dude,
he's like laughing and embarrassed because he's He doesn't look
good here. Like, the cold laugh right there? Is that why you
Saltman chatting? No, they'd have a falling out for one, and
then
two, Dan's not good at on the
The fact Dan's absolutely abysmal at it, no, Dan wouldn't be
telling him what to say. I don't know anything about this guy.
Maybe he is cosplaying. I have no clue. I don't know why Casson
is doing
It sounds like he would just ignore this guy and never interact
with him ever. But again, this is a guy who like loses his chat
every day, so in a video shouting at me from afar. Well, you
put how you stood down when I asked what you do about it to stop
me in the video.
So, I denied him the clip.
I said something really Dude, I'm really >> There's no
way that you've been on a 6-minute 40-second rant after like
15 Uh Zafiana, thank you for the new sub. Thank you. Thank you.
New individual sub. Appreciate it. Thank you. That person's not
chatting.
tweets about this. And then your position is I Last Last chat
I see from them. Stop talking with your mouth full. Wow. So true.
Thank you for the new individual sub. I appreciate it. Anyway.
That By the way, that's from February 23rd, not tonight. >> denied
him the clip. Bro, you just created clips for everyone else.
I I don't What are we talking about here, dude? You created the
discourse. Dude, I denied It's It's like an 8-hour stream. What
do you want me to do? Not eat any food during an 8-hour stream?
I don't want to do that. The annoying is diabolical work here.
The end was this. Don't worry, you're not worth making a video
about. You can rest You can rest easy that that beautiful video
I took won't be online. So, why did you take it? I have no idea
what the end game is here. Like, most of the time I can kind
of see like a trajectory of where he hopes to go. I actually
think he's just really Maximum cope. He's like silent, and I
don't think this is just regular dead air. This is like advanced
dead
He's not You know how he's You know This is how you know he's
mad. He just went on a 7-minute rant, and a chat message didn't
send him into a spiral. Unless it's been clipped to somewhere
that I'm not sure. He's been locked in, and he's never this locked
in. His girlfriend lying about the interaction cuz they don't
plan to post the video. Well, what are you talking about? I was
there. There was no screaming. No one was even paying attention.
He walked up to you and said, "You're hurting Palestinians."
He and ran away.
So, now we have opposing testimony, and he's like saying that
this girl felt uncomfortable as well. So, like, why are you saying
that she's lying when you've assigned the way that she feels?
Yeah, it's funny because some of your ah the truth. Not a single
Not a single person that was in Who is recording? Was Was Hassan
recording? I know like they were recording, right? If they go
up to Hassan, they be recording. Bald has denied the interaction
except for the Then just release the entire clip then.
I I can't believe cuz he said the entire clip I assume some of
it was out there. None of it's out there.
Post the whole interaction.
Do it. We didn't film it. He did. He's like a Oh, here we go.
This flash to flash I missed it. Um So what is this one now?
Oh this Wait this has to be the same clip, right? There's no
way this is Oh no no it's on the screen. Zionizing to gaslight
someone with such shameless narcissistic psychopathic audacity
that you deny reality in their face while simultaneously playing
the victim, engaging in endless circular debates that go nowhere,
and displaying complete lack of empathy and basic
How is there a word Zionist that just doesn't have Israel or
or something like Like these aren't even mentioned terms. Zionist
now means something that's entirely separated from anything related
to Zionism. That's good. Okay. All right, that's a that's a thing.
Holy bro. This is this is just a lot. There's a lot to process
here. What the bro? I I I'm kind of lost here. Hassan doesn't
get enough hate. I think that's the big takeaway from this segment.
I wonder um how lying about the one being uncomfortable will
help people in Cuba. I don't think any of this stuff helps people
in Cuba. I think it's all performative cringe. I think it's designed
to Dude. Wait, what? Hold on. I'm I'm letting this go too fast.
God damn it. That's my bad. That's I wonder um how lying about
the one being uncomfortable will help people in Cuba. I don't
think any of this stuff helps people in Cuba. I think it's all
performative cringe. I think it's designed to continue like Did
he donate his entire super chat earnings or whatever for that
trip to Cuba or something? Was that something that he
I If he hasn't donated far more than he made in any of his streams
and donations to this trip, to something to do with this trip,
I'd be shocked. I would be totally shocked.
How much could he have even made? Didn't he stream like 3 and
1/2 hours the whole
Apparently he just handed wads of cash out. Like what What content
is he
If this guy filmed a little documentary in 24 hours of him like
doing good deeds or like real humanitarian effort stuff in Cuba,
then I will owe him an apology. But it sounds like he just went
there for a a fun Cuban vacation.
Um Don't be ridiculous. I mean it's possible. Maybe he filmed
stuff that he's not telling us and he's waiting for everyone
to bite the bullet uh and make fun of him so he can come out
and go no actually here's all the [__] that I really
did, losers. You guys are so Here's the question. If If people
are setting this up and they're organizing a bunch of aid, they're
taking like a bunch of medical supplies and and they reach out
to Hassan and they say, "Hey, we'd appreciate you if you come
like document this, talk to people, just broadly like promote
the trip so that we can get eyes on the issue."
Is it Is it wrong to say that Hassan was involved in the aid
project, that he was a part of the group that brought aid? Cuz
I see some people arguing that like, "Well, he didn't pay for
anything. He didn't get all this stuff together." It's like,
"Well, but they reached out to him and wanted him to be a part
of the project." I assume they had a reason for that. Didn't
reach out to him
Right? So again, I just don't know like what are we looking for?
It obviously helped. It obviously was a fruitful
Many people did helpful things for the Cuban people there.
I just don't know what are we
What did we expect? We also don't know how much he gave dollars
wise. Well, I'd just say like even if he didn't give anything
dollars wise, he didn't do something bad by going.
That's just objectively not true.
Yeah, exactly. Like they want They want Hassan involved so people
will look at the stuff. That was why they invited
If they invited him to fundraise, they'd probably say, "Hey Hassan,
could you fundraise for us?" And then I assume if he was going,
he would go, "Yeah, I'll fundraise for you." and give people
links and promote it on his stream and say go give money here.
Right? Yeah, I know Matt, but um it it's just like it's so goofy.
Even if he did
even if he did nothing like that, he still helped. It was still
a positive
And people can't even give that away. People can't even The bare
minimum is this trip was helpful.
Hassan was a part of it. That's the bare minimum. Just Just say
that. And move on to anything else. Literally any other topic.
Any You could say Hassan's bad for a million other reasons. God.
Did you see this? I did not see whatever Ben Shapiro put out.
Nope, not yet. Nick heard flotilla and thought of floating tortilla.
Well, he he was pronouncing flotilla as flotia earlier, so realistically
that that theory holds a lot of water, okay?
He was just saying flotia over and over
Are you desperate or whatever? Like If he pulled some of that
[__] fair play. Fair play.
the painted nails and the whole thing, dude.
Like this is like I'm making fun of Adam McIntyre like, "Hey
guy Hey guys, I'm going to be supporting Palestine. I've decided
that we're going to go on tour and we're going to go to Gaza
Strip. Yay! [screaming] We're going to do a free show in Gaza
for everyone out there so we can hopefully build up a lot of
money for like that that would Yeah, I don't know, dude. Stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Please stop. Dude, I'm telling you could you
not see that So you'd hopefully build up a lot of money. He
He almost got there. So you'd like get money for these people
or Another fem voice opportunity.
He does love that voice. He does totally love that voice, yes.
Are accents offensive or not? Well, no. It's It's You're being
a hypocrite if you do an accent. Nicholas, he doesn't believe
accents are bad. He loves accents. that happening? Could you
not see that
>> Guys, we're going to be saving Gaza. We're going to
go out there. Hi mockers. More Adam.
>> Dude, everyone unanimously is like, "I cannot watch
any Adam. Please stop covering Adam. We hate him too, but we
do not want to hear any more Adam ever ever again." I refuse
to imagine that. I could see that happening. The only reason
it wouldn't is because Adam would just feel like he would he
would never in a million years like actually go to a location
like that. But uh unless maybe views are really far Hassan says
he had to stay at that hotel. But did they have to throw an Irish
rap rave that did nothing for the Cuban people? [laughter]
Dude, they sent out socialists and everyone's like, "Wait."
Again, already planned event.
There used to be an already planned event that they were running.
The Irish band went up and did a couple songs cuz they were asked
to.
And they went on with their day. >> Holy What the cuz that
smell? They all just start running down the street. sound effect
of of the other zombies in Left 4 Dead, too. Add that Add that
to the meme. Holy [__]
That hat is awful. I do believe Sophia said earlier that the
hat makes her want
It does sort of look like a short stack, doesn't it? Not the
goblin variety. Like pancakes, okay? Like a couple different
layers of pancake almost. What the [__] is that?
>> Almost. Actually the law Yeah, the US government is
what stopped him from saving the country. If the US government
would just lift their sanctions, Hassan [__] could
save the entire Cuban
That's funny. >> no no no no. Not Like I see one, two,
three layers there possibly of pancake,
Not even just a single stack, but like a Yeah, one, two, possibly
three. Up to three pancakes. Speaking of Left 4 Dead, I heard
that Turkey Tom's accuser did like a pri- People are like, "Tom's
ex DMCA'd a video." It's not entirely true. Tom's ex is being
accused of doing a privacy complaint to take down uh I think
it's It's Sly Boy is his name? Like a Turkey Tom video.
No, removed by Tom's ex. So that's funny that Left 4 Dead came
up in my ramble.
Is that a I think that's a thing that's happening right now.
I saw that on my feed. Is that on your feed, Leia Serpentite?
Serpente?
No, I don't think it's on your feed. Someone was talking about
it, but I didn't see it. Thank you for having Epic Gamer Clips.
I appreciate it. It's a privacy complaint? I was told it was
a privacy complaint. Let me try to Let me lore dump on this one
real fast. Bro Shoshos.
Uh Sly Boy said
Turkey privacy complaint. She was also in my DMs before it got
removed. Still talking [__] about him. Visibility
[clears throat] removed. So yeah, people were saying it was a
DMCA. This is like actually the person claiming Wait, hold
Did he remove the parts that exposed her
Cuz I thought they basically take timestamps and they cut around
timestamps. But Or like you could you could basically remove
The way a privacy complaint works is you get a notice and then
you can remove the parts that have that person's identity there.
And if you do that, then you tell YouTube to review it and they
review it and then if it's removed all the [__] you're
fine.
That's like how it's supposed to work.
Did he just ignore it? Cuz I'm guessing he doxxed her, right?
Why Why are we pretending that that's not what it I saw a comment
that he used her face in the thumbnail. Yeah, that's bad. That's
obviously bad.
I If he did that. But it's like that's what a privacy complaint
is. Hey, you're like putting my doxx on here or something. It's
weird, man. thing that it got removed.
Um But yeah, that's a That's a interesting. Moey and Dennis are
today. Yeah. That wouldn't be the first time that we've said
the name on stream. We tried for like a solid episode, but at
this point there's really not much else I could do. I should
make a special infected Left 4 Dead. Have Hassan be the tank,
Mike from PA be the boomer, and Dennis be the spitter. Jesus
Christ. All right, guys. Um somehow we have done half a segment
in 3 and 1/2 hours. So I'm going to hit the bathroom break and
I guess iDubbz is going to be our segment 3 for tonight. We need
a video. One more One more quick thing I think all the dis tracks
were completely fake. And your family always has your back. And
properly didn't need to
has been caught bugging that we have to [__] Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. The Something funny has happened.
Something funny Okay, here we go. Internet comment etiquette.
This video is sponsored by Israel.
Oh, is this going to be a dog whistle channel? Internet comment
etiquette with Eric? Is this going to be a dog whistle
That they're going to say this is actually an anti-Semitic dog
whistle and then Nick's going to laugh about it. >> Funny has
happened. We have to cover it right now. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Something ridiculously funny has just occurred.
I have Guys, this is the most insane stream I've We've had. This
is just off the wall. >> for it. Something funny has happened.
>> If you guys might know this person from the H3 Podcast
or he collaborates with Jacksfilms. He uploaded a video 7 hours
ago called Internet comment etiquette. This video is sponsored
by Israel.
Dude. Dude. So what happened was So what happened was this guy
had a video from
Is this really Dude, he he popped it That laugh go through its
paces tonight. >> that he shelved it has to be released
because he's contractually obligated to post this video >> now.
There's nothing he can do about it. He had to
Hey students. I Somebody told me this is like a fake laugh. He
appears to be sincerely laughing and that actually scares me
What What is so funny right now? He's contractually obligated.
Does Nick hate this guy? I don't even know what the What's funny
right now.
now. There's nothing he can do about [laughter] it. He had to
It's so awesome. What the [__] is funny? Go.
Students, um Dude, what? Hey students. Hey guys, I hate to be
the bearer of bad news on this one, but uh yeah. So, listen,
I've I've been working with a company, little known company known
as Israel on this one. Oh, yeah. Hey
um just real quick Could you imagine if this video is completely
psychotic? It's like, "Today, we're going to be doing the show
from a from a synagogue. Yeah, no. I mean, listen, we're here
on the first day of Hanukkah and um this is kind of crazy. Like
Hey students, uh What? Yeah, is he high or something? What's
going on? Just real quick, I wanted to give a little disclaimer
before today's video. I just want to let you guys know that I
filmed this back in 2019. Um and then 2020 happened and nobody
was traveling, so I I put it on the shelf. I didn't think I was
ever going to have to upload this. But then the sponsor reminded
me that I signed a contract. Dude, this has to be a joke, bro.
There's no way. This is the perfect palate cleanser. I don't
believe this is real. So, it's it's got to go up. Shut the [__]
Dude, there's no sponsor that would be like, "Listen to that
2019 video you've been holding back for 7 years." Shut the [__]
As you're >> It It has to be Guys, it has to be. Please
remember that this was filmed 6 years ago. Dude, what the [__]
What are we going to cut to? It's going to be absolutely diabolical.
All right.
Dude, it's going to be him wearing a full outfit. >> we'll
try. Dude, it's going to be awesome. It would be funny if this
was sincere and he was like touring Israel or something. Doritos
watching anti-Israel >> Ethan Klein is going to be mad.
Dude, How awesome would it be if it's just him like walking around
watching like hate crimes happen to Arabs and and Israelis like
explaining how normal it is. It's fine. No, you don't understand.
That person was a
That would be funny. >> to Sorry, just as like a skit,
>> it. Obviously.
Let's Let's roll it. If it The only way I would think this is
real is if the video has literally no Okay, I've been spoiled.
Dude, it's gigantic flag immediately. This video I was dreaming
about this last night and after watching Nick's stream, I'm kind
of [__] blackpilled on this This [__]
video
No, it's the same [__] time. But this video is sponsored
by Israel. Hey, mazel tov. All right, what do we have here? Hey,
mazel tov. Grease your investigations. Hey, students and welcome
to a very Grease.
Bro, what? Uh this is a mistake. And And next time I'm like telling
you guys we're going to cover Doritos, I just tell me not to.
Unless I have timestamps. We went to this like live. This is
a mistake. This is just a
This is very small Grease your investigations. That makes a ton
of sense with the Illuminati all-seeing eye right there, yeah?
Grease your investigations. >> Grease your investigations.
I don't want Grease your cheeks, dude. >> special episode.
That's right. Today, we are sponsored by Israel. Dude, shut the
[__] up. The beautiful country full of beautiful,
happy people ready to welcome you to their land. So, go over
[laughter] to israel.com/bigmoney
for 10% off your
Okay, now it's really fake laughter. Now big money Now, I've
got so much to say, but only if it's good content I dedicate
in a comment section where every >> This is not Yeah, of
course it's not 7 years ago. Everyone also loves Israel, too.
Unless, of course, they're anti-Semites. 68 facts you probably
didn't know about Israel. 68, that's an odd number. Why stop
there? When you hear the word Israel, what goes through your
mind? Nothing much. >> Israel is a young country. How young?
Just 68 years old. Oh, that's why it's 68 facts. Wow, I can't
wait to see next
>> Israel is among the 10 leading countries in life expectancy.
Folks there live on average to the ripe old age of 83.
What Dude, what is he Is this guy gay?
Oh, damn, that's old. >> was blah blah video. Dude, this
is
I can't I've never like nobody's making actual comedy about this
topic at all. Everybody's just like fearmongering and crying.
And then internet comment at it just drops a like an armbar,
dude. Israel. Like an RKO out of nowhere. >> .com/bigmoney
What?
Nobody's joking about Israel paying for Nobody's joking about
Israel doing
What? Has he blocked the entirety of that section of the internet?
So, he's unaware that this is happening
This is literally happening consistently
all across the internet. What? >> Israel has 273 km of
beach. Maybe Is he doing like uh Is this doing Is this like a
commentary? Like Is he doing a bit? Is he doing a satire that
like
I No, he's not. He's >> Mediterranean Sea, the Red Sea,
the Dead Sea. Oh, that's that's all Israel. Oh, that's incredible.
>> Tel Aviv is not just Tel Aviv is in the top 10 for cities
with the world's most beautiful women. And yes, also among the
top 10 when it comes to good-looking >> Also, Quentin Tarantino
just moved there and everybody loves him. So, oh my god, dude.
Yeah, Quentin Tarantino is kind of on the outs right now cuz
he just attacked Shaggy from the Scooby-Doo
That is the length of my knowledge on
That is exact I did not word it that way to be funny. That is
exactly how it was That was how I understood it. What was invented
here? The technology that allows us to chat in WhatsApp Messenger
and everything else you youngsters spend your time on. The world's
first antivirus software. That was 3 months ago. This video was
filmed like 2 days ago, guys. >> Guys,
Israel isn't a isn't a product. >> man, I can't wait to
visit. >> anti-jellyfish sting gel, laser keyboard, the
technology that enabled unmanned flight, cherry tomatoes, and
Rummikub, the popular board game. Whoa, cherry tomatoes were
an invention? I didn't know that. Thanks, Israel. >> Time
magazine has crowned Tel Aviv as gay capital Nick, what is I'm
He's talking about this video is in >> of the Middle East.
Okay. What is his his recommended videos on the side there? Why
is urine in all caps? What is that? the popular board >> Whoa,
cherry tomatoes were an invention? I didn't know that. Thanks,
Israel. Dude, there's going to be so many good clips from this.
>> Time out magazine has crowned Tel Aviv as gay capital
of the Middle East. Okay, well, I don't know if there's a runner-up
for that one. Have you heard of the Global Happiness Index?
>> Wait, that actually makes me laugh. >> Neither
did I until now. But apparently, Israelis are in the 11th spot
out of 196
>> All right, well, if you ask me, Israel's pretty awesome
and I don't have anything bad to say.
>> Got it. And neither do the people in this comment section.
Love Israel from Iran. I wish I could visit Israel one >> That's
great, bro. Maybe they'll come to >> I am from Dude, is
this guy Dude, this has got to be one of the funniest videos
I've ever seen.
Someone just said Dude, this video is not funny at all. Bro,
this is one of the This is one of the funniest videos I've ever
seen. Dude, he said the chat and his chat. Wait, I know how I
could have made this funny. I could have just watched his chat.
I could have just watched the chat the whole time. This is
I love Israel and their people, even though I am To be fair,
he's tuned himself to laugh at Ethan Klein's Instagram stories.
So, realistically, this probably is high comedy to him.
You know what I'm saying? Like he's laughing so hard at Ethan's
Instagram stories, he's got to laugh at this.
Somebody at least put some effort into this, right? Israeli love
from Jamaica in the Caribbean. >> Love Israel from Canada.
Love from Saudi Arabia. Israel Why is Saudi Arabia sound like
a just great. Get over it, Muslims. >> Love from Czech
Republic. It's good when individuals live in harmony. >> I
agree.
If there's one thing that I know about the Middle East, it's
that everyone lives together in harmony. >> You see, the
whole world loves Israel and I love leaving relevant YouTube
comments. Yo, I be It is funny though because if this actually
was from 2019, all of your favorite social media influencers
would sound like this, >> shoving eggs >> Everyone
loves Israel except for that one weird batch of skeptic anti-Semite
YouTubers. So, my boyfriend's because they're so cheap. Hey,
you guys hear about this new actor, Jonathan Majors? I think
he's got a big career
>> as big as my respect for Israel, which has accomplished
so much in so little time. I can't believe Dude, this is definitely
2019. buy a house there. A bunch of property suddenly becomes
available. Anyway, I'm out of here. Got to go see Avengers: Endgame
at my local
theater that will stay open forever.
Dude, there's you
I'm sorry. You guys can love this guy. This is like not that
It's It's not that It's not that good. It's not that good a >> Shalom
and post. Oh, yeah, life is good. Life is good. I mean, I don't
like our president right now, but whatever. This is the last
time we're ever going How is he belly laughing at every single
joke? I think there's some shred of humor here, okay?
And Nick has like he's attuned himself
He His sensors are
maxed out right now. He's He's so sensitive to any form of humor,
so he can laugh at Ethan Klein's jokes. I will >> he's
listening to anybody else and he's just dying. >> Ruben
donated $3.
Yeah, we was kings. Thank you for the Jonathan Majors comment.
I appreciate it, Ruben Ruben. Thank you. We're going to have
to do All right, dude. This right now, but whatever. This is
the last time we're ever going to have to do Dude, he didn't
even let the punchline finish that time. theater that will stay
[laughter] open forever. Shalom and post. Oh, yeah, life is good.
Life is good. I mean, I don't like our president right now, but
whatever. This is the last time we're ever going to have to do
All right, dude. This guy is goated. I've never actually watched
a video from him before, but this has made me a fan. That pissed
This is some [__] that I would watch on Shop from
the Point with Tommy C back in like 2020.
Like a video of this Like this is like a Aha. Remember Remember
Tommy? Remember Tommy C? >> He'd watch like a Jacksfilms
video on stream. of Israel, I think I'm going to be okay. Some
[__] we would just sit down and laugh at for the
entire show. >> Dude, they are going to be the most off.
They really?
Well, who else gets off at this video? Liberal arts college students.
Oh.
Oh, I must say something horrible. This is the best video of
2019. Yeah, it's a >> This is a way more entertaining to
watch. This is absolutely awesome. You should watch the full
video. Go watch the full video.
Wait, Nick is a Tommy C fan?
Wait, Matt. You're joking around, right? I think you're joking
around. I can't see the satire, okay? It's text. It's
I only know about Tommy C from Wait, how do you not know that
Tommy C Nick used to work for Tommy C? Nick used to do streams
with Tommy C. Nick is Tommy C's like Sorry, yeah, Nick is like
Tommy C's golden boy. Tommy C used to collect young children
and groom them into YouTubers, okay?
Not even really joking. Kind of like
It actually was like that. Obviously, but
>> Bro, you're a genius.
It's too bad you're going to lose a lot of that IQ when you get
into a boxing match in 3 years.
You're going to what? No, nothing. Just leave your leave your
comment. >> Okay. And remember, don't go to any of the
follow-up ones. He's talking about creator clash. on the next
video I had queued up here.
Oh my god. And it smells like and [__] all the time.
Well, move to What? Israel. Come on, there's a bunch of you New
Yorkers there already. Wow, hold on. Hey, listen, man. Listen,
I was say I was singing your praises. That way young people in
New York can stop relying on polyamorous relationships
All right, that one that one's actually not me. >> And you
guys get to move right next to the beach like you planned to
do in Florida before God started firing his hurricane machine
gun across the Gulf of Mexico. Don't you want to get away from
all the liberal that comes with living in New York? Aren't you
sick of woke leftist scum? Are we going to get a Zorman and Domer
Like Russell Brand and Gwen Stefani ruining America? Bring your
conservative values with you to Tel Aviv where progressivism
[laughter] is still young enough to be stamped out. There's plenty
of jobs for elderly New Yorkers in Israel, too. Depending on
how old you are, we'll probably give you a job where you're sitting
most of the time. Like inside the cockpit of an American fighter
jet. Plus Dude, honestly,
it's so funny watching like a anti-Israel video
that is not made by like an untalented
titty streamer or like a a guy going to Cuba with a dollar ring.
Like this is
I think Nick just doesn't look for this kind of content.
This kind of content's everywhere.
Okay, all right. All right. I think I'm done with with Nick for
the night.